I laughed. It's all I could do. [music] I just laughed. And then,
I think maybe the second thing I did was I went and I got all
my hard drives and I buried them in the woods. I walked out to
the woods with a shovel and I buried my hard drives. I know that
sounds really bad, but it genuinely wasn't because I had anything
to hide. If you
>> I was kind of thinking we'd lead with this. It is a
little bit long.
The video is long, but this is Lauren Southern doing So, what
what does she Intelligence agents showed up at my door late last
year. I told them to leave. They proceeded to call me from anonymous
numbers repeatedly, contacted my gym, told me they wouldn't go
away unless I built a relationship with them as an asset. Your
audience will never know.
Returned to speak with me multiple times claiming they were giving
me last chances before they before they threw me to the wolves.
They told me that the courts wouldn't care if I was actually
guilty or not. That essentially someone had to take the fall
and I could ensure it wasn't me. It was repeatedly implied to
me that you're smart, you know it's not what's what's true that
matters, it's the perception. I was made to believe there was
a potential arrest
Made to believe I could never travel to the US again without
being arrested by the FBI. Made to believe I might not be around
to see my child grow up. None of these things were true. I can
enter the US without issue. I was never arrested. I did nothing
wrong. I was psychologically manipulated for months in an attempt
to turn me into a government asset. We have one-party consent
in Canada. I believe it is in the public interest for people
to understand how this works as I know I'm not the only one.
I have nothing else against the agent. He was just given instructions
and a job. But I have no doubt if his job were to destroy my
life and try to jail me based on perception, not truth, he would
do it. I'm just doing my job as well by publishing this. These
are just a few excerpts cut from hours of conversations to give
people an idea of our conversations. Ow,
this is going to be cut down a lot. We'll have to see.
Do we Oh, man, I don't know about this.
Hours of conversations cut down to just a few minutes for video?
Ah, man, I hope she she's going to release the raw conversations,
right?
I hope.
You got to hope that she would release the the full combos. We'll
see. Maybe she does. Maybe she does. All right. So, she she put
this on Twitter a couple hours ago? 2 hours ago. Already at 200,000
views. Already at 2,000 200,000 views.
How can we forget the honey potting? Fool me once. Oh. I don't
really want to watch these cuz they're going to be in the video,
right? I kind of want to just watch the full video. I don't I
don't want to I just I'll do the the tweets as a teaser, but
I kind of want to watch the full video. Lauren Southern tried
so many scams and grifts, but this one is true for sure. This
thing is is I sit here, I know this the the this just dropped
2 hours ago, right? And there's 200,000 views on it, 2.7k likes,
700 retweets. And I'm sitting here like, how can people have
opinions on this?
The the video that accompanies this is like an hour and 53 minutes
long or something. How can you 2 hours later, it's like got all
of these comments, all of this commentary?
How are these people How do these people know what's going on,
right? Hour 30. Hour 30.
They're just like
I don't know. We'll see. I feel like I'm a little skeptical.
Oh. Also, only 5,000 views on the video and I'm like three of
them. The grift didn't
Um
I do believe that one was not to get charges through. Or sorry,
not charges. I do believe that one was not to make money. Jesus.
It might be to make get charges go through, but it was not to
make money, I don't think. This one could be. This one I remember
hearing about. She's actually leaned totally into this, right?
Like like she's been telling this story in fewer words than this
for a long time. It was basically at her trial and we watched
her trial in Canada or or her testimony in Canada. She said essentially
the same thing, right? Like the government agents were telling
me I'd lose my kid if I didn't if I didn't help them out. She
didn't uh It's not like I was unaware that this was an allegation
against the Canadian government by her. She's made it quite a
few times. Now she's doing a video on it and she's including
recordings.
Lauren Southern fell off so hard. She has no community or real
base of support left. Um
I don't know.
I think she doesn't have a massive base of support, but you can
be like a creator without a massive base of support. Canadian
intelligence try intelligence agent tries to recruit alt-right
YouTuber Lauren Southern. She refuses. I wonder how many YouTubers
are paid assets.
Hold on. They're I'm almost positive they were trying to get
Lauren to engage in being an asset because she was close to Lauren
Chen, because she was close to like this Russian operation, right?
It's not like it's not like they're going to a YouTuber and being
like, "Hey, defend Israel and we'll give you a bunch of money."
That's a I feel like that's what a whole bunch of people are
going to say from this. Israel just does that directly, okay?
You think Israel's going to hand over money to other governments
to do it? Come on. You know, this is serious business and I need
to wake up and realize that there is like
like like the police might be coming and putting me in a handcuffs
kind of situation. And I didn't even like that wasn't that was
kind of this situation in my head where it's like, "No, surely
that can't be it." Eventually, the other shoe does drop. Open
the door and there's the police with two a man and a woman in
like leather jackets, black outfits that bring out a badge that
says CSIS on it, CSIS, which is our like FBI, CIA equivalent
in Canada. And I understand what you're doing right now. You
can be well once that blows over. But I want to tell you like
there's something in motion right now. This is
>> like this is not going away anytime soon. Well, I love
Let me back up to you. From our last meeting, a lot of people
especially my colleagues, they're like, "All right, she doesn't
want to cooperate. So, I'm like kind of feed her off to the wolves
head. Just let her Again, it when you're in the like the
Uh is this just Pixie with a voice changer who's asking Lauren
Southern questions or who's trying to intimidate
Can this guy get rid of the valley girls? What is happening?
It's the percep All right, she doesn't want to From our last
meeting, a lot of people especially my colleagues Especially
my colleagues. They're like >> uh All right, she doesn't
want to cooperate. So, I'm like kind of >> they're like
kind of like you know, like
Again, it when you're in the like the courtroom, it's the perception.
Not about the truth of it. >> Now, how much is that? That
sounds perception. Not about when you're in the like the courtroom,
it's the perception.
Not about the truth of it. Like this could be going in a lot
of different directions. I don't know if that's like a contigu
contiguous
I'd want to know from the audio of this like is this is any of
this edited
Hey guys, it's been over a year since I last posted on YouTube
and a lot has happened since then. A lot. First of all, this
is not a channel relaunch, so don't get too excited. Whatever
Okay. By the way, I just put intelligence agents despite knowing
that it's Canadian intelligence agents cuz I know it makes the
title way better. I put that in my title on Twitter. I put that
in my title on Twitch, on Kick, right? I'm like I'm totally not
going to let anybody know via the title that it's Canadian intelligence
cuz as soon as people figure that out, they'd just be like, "Oh,
that's boring. It's not the FBI. Oh, that's boring." So, we're
just rolling. All right. >> my online career was a year
ago it's dead, buried
rest in peace, equal parts government intervention and my own
choices, both good and bad. Where to even begin? Uh I guess we'll
start with where I'm at now and then we will work our way back
to the absolute chaos that prompted my current view on the world.
I've spent the last year living mostly offline. You know, I have
my lapses here and there, but not really posting that much, not
scrolling as Okay, I need the Do you think Tectone looked at
Lauren Southern as like the blueprint for what he wanted to do?
Like I'm going to go take a break. I'm going to be offline, but
I'm going to just come back all the time and make allegations
and and participate for a little bit and then I'm I and I'm always
going to insist that it's not about money, it's not about anything
like that. I I feel like the whole time
Lauren Southern is Now, I don't think the Andrew Tate thing was
about making money, but the whole time I
believe that she's hoping she can rebuild her audience, rebuild
like this career. Like for sure.
I don't know why she has to constantly do the cope that she's
not doing that. Like you are doing that and you don't have to
apologize. Just don't Stop trying to lie to me about it. Please,
just stop lying. Like I'm here for whatever you're doing, but
please stop lying. Stop saying that that's not what you're doing
cuz it is what you're doing. as much working a normal job. Thank
the Lord I was even able to get one. That was a miracle. And
just kind of reconnecting with reality, community, friends, family.
And it has been surprisingly refreshing. There is a lot of things
you forget about when you get caught up in online e-politics,
whatever it is. And you know, it's not that I didn't get offers
to go back into that world, uh the media game, when my
job blew up late last year. We'll talk about that. I got a lot
of big shiny gigs on camera and off, you know, put on silver
platters for me. You can make documentaries again, Lauren. You
can do planning in the background and still be involved in this
space. I why? I that doesn't really make any sense to me.
That doesn't make any sense to me at all because her last comeback
was
with Tenet Media and she didn't take a big salary. She wasn't
getting paid good
So, why would she get caught up in this Tenet Media scandal and
then people are like, "Hey, we'll still pay you a whole bunch
of money." That doesn't make any sense to me.
That that's super confusing
to me
that she would go, "Oh yeah, these companies also want to pay
me." Why? Like what? They didn't want to pay you before you had
the Tenet media scandal. Why would they want She didn't say work,
she said, "Oh, there's gold She said it was pretty good." And
just kind of reconnecting with reality, community, friends, family
and has been surprisingly refreshing. There is a lot of things
you forget about when you get caught up in online e-politics,
whatever it is. And you know, it's not that I didn't get offers
to go back into that world, the media game, when my
job blew up late last year. We'll talk about that. Oh, she's
talking about Tenet, I see. >> I got a lot of big shiny
gigs on camera and off, you know. So, I got a So, when Tenet
happened, I got a whole bunch of big shiny gigs on and off camera.
Put on silver platters for me. You can make documentaries again,
Laura, and you can do planning in the background and still be
involved in this space. But I very deliberately turned them all
down. Why would I do that? So, if they were good offers, if they
were if they were actually good offers, why would she have taken
the Tenet media one? Cuz obviously her reputation, her prestige
went down from the Tenet media
Why was she working at Tenet media in the first place? That wasn't
an incredible offer. Um I think
there's very obvious spiritual and mental health reasons one
would exit this space. But on a more sinister level and one that
I think is important to share is that
I was beginning to wonder if it was even possible to exist in
the political media space anymore without being owned by governments,
corporations, or cults. Often all three at once in my opinion.
And if not those things,
I find even creators that have managed to be totally independent
these days really struggle with audience capture. Just that feedback
loop of what do people want to hear me say rather than what is
accurate and what are my actual opinions. Like this the way of
framing that, it's like okay. all three at once. Is even possible
to exist in the >> wondering if it's even possible to expect
exist in the political space without being owned by governments,
cults, or media space anymore without being owned by governments,
corporations, or cults. >> corporations or cults. Often
all three.
I hope she gives any explanation what that comment means. I just
want any explanation at all. and all three at once in my opinion.
And if not those
I find even creators that have managed to be totally independent
these days really struggle with audience capture. Just that feedback
loop of what do people want to hear me say rather than what is
accurate and what are my actual opinions. I think it is undeniable
that everything online is feeling increasingly less authentic,
a whole lot crazier, and a whole lot less reflective of reality.
I spent a decade like my Again, I I I don't know. I just In a
video essay, I feel like you could give like an example
I I hate when people talk, they like do all this like stuff.
They like lay the groundwork for what they're going to say. And
then I have to invest in watching the whole hour and a half thing.
I've got no idea if she's even close to on the mark here. Right?
Like I I've got no idea and I I would just love if in her intro
it could be a little better. It could be feel a little more like
tangible to me. my entire adult life in the political sphere
and it is impossible for me not to notice the constant blatant
manipulation,
opinions being formed by astroturfing and bots, everyone just
pumping out content based on headlines they've barely skimmed.
I seriously don't trust anything people send me I find that one
Google search I do for an opposing source almost always debunks
every fact I think I know. And the worst part is I know most
people aren't doing this. Most people didn't spend their life
in political media and grow extremely skeptical of the news,
so they're just not going out of their way to do to Google, you
know, opposing sources. Instead, people's algorithms have schismed
most of us into utterly different realities that are all Okay,
I don't need Lauren Southern to Did she She just read some Jonathan
Haidt for the first time in her mind? She read Jonathan Haidt
and she's like, "Listen,
Jonathan Haidt's precise ideas have never been said by a blonde
woman, a blonde Canadian woman. So, I think there's a lane to
cook here." Okay. fine-tuned to give us the perfect ideological
lap dance. Oh, yeah, what do you want to hear, baby? You're right,
you're so right about everything. Never question anything in
your life. Those people every single one of them is evil, but
not you. You've got it all figured out. We've entered a kind
of hyperreality,
a total break from truth that I don't know I don't even know
how to engage with anymore. The internet that I started on when
I was younger on the old blogging forums where everyone's Everyone
that has joined is kind of this nerdy person that You are Dylan
Burns for Canadians, glasshouse, bro.
In what Is there a dimension in which that makes sense, Canadian
collar? You just said some insane [__] for no
Where Where In what What In what way?
that's really interested in the topic and no one's getting paid
to talk about it. They're there because they really care and
want to figure things out. Uh and it was all posted on and moderated
by real human beings.
That's just gone. The wild west got conquered and not just by
robots and algorithms, but by people in power and they've somehow
convinced everyone it's still free and open and that all the
interactions are totally real. Like I don't know. I started doing
like dissident politics in 2015.
And you know, I wasn't getting I wasn't getting paid when I started.
If anything, I was paying to be involved in it because it was
just fascinating. I want to be here. I want to have these
And the other people that joined that space were were in the
same position and I don't think
like the media large media platforms, Fox News Okay, I think
I'm trying to I'm trying to figure out what my precise criticism
here cuz I get very annoyed. What is my criticism because I get
very annoyed watching this? When somebody's laying out an idea
that I don't think is unique or special or really particularly
interesting,
I want them to like like hey, lots of people said for a long
time,
"Oh, everybody's bought and paid for." If you have some evidence
of people being bought and paid for beyond just saying what every
hippie for the past 50 years has said, "Oh, the entire political
space is bought and paid for by corporations, man." as they take
a hit of a joint, then go ahead if you got something new or unique
to share. But I don't need the hippie rant. I've We've all heard
the hippie rant from total who aren't worth listening to. I don't
need it again. Say you've got something new. Say you've got something
interesting or shut the [__] up. Jesus. >> CNN
everything. I They didn't know what to make of YouTube. They
didn't know what to make There was no concept of like a random
person in their basement getting famous talking about politics.
There were gatekeepers you had to go through, right? Uh and I
really thought it was going to be this like liberation device
when the internet came about. Oh my goodness, the average person
can get their opinion out there and we can have a voice and engage
in the discussion. This is going to be amazing.
But obviously, I think the people in power looked at that and
the people who like money, like eyeballs on their things, get
money from getting eyeballs on their stuff.
They They They learned. They learned and they grew and slowly
what was a free internet became more and more constrained, but
they also learned that people want to think it's free. People
want to think it's authentic.
Uh yeah, I don't know what this Victor This Victor Sharp guy
is like offended that Lauren Southern's on the screen. I don't
I don't know what to tell you, dude. If you don't like it, there's
like a million other options on Kick. You can go watch anyone
on Kick. You can go over to YouTube, youtube.com. There's a ton
of content there. If you don't like it, just go watch anything
else, brother.
You don't have to get outraged. I'm watching it because I happen
to have followed a lot of her story since she like retired from
politics and it's interesting to me, which is the only metric
by which content for this stream is is decided on, okay? How
interesting is it to me? Nobody cares how interesting it is to
you. It's just me. It's all about me. Good luck. authentic and
need to think it's that way. And um yeah, I joined the dissident
political sphere because I wanted to hold truth to power, question
institutions, question the government and and anyone that amasses
too much control in their hands. Meanwhile, I feel like a ton
of the dissident sphere that I joined
is watching power being amassed in places, but because it's in
their favor is not questioning it. They're under this impression
that some massive victory has been made eternally for free speech
and for truth, but as far as I can tell, we're not really watching
a revolution of truth seekers. It kind of feels like we're watching
the old machine rebrand
Every influencer with a paycheck calls themsel- Yeah, obviously.
I I'm waiting for her to say anything interesting or anything
revelatory. call themselves a truth seeker these days. Every
Save the West account is seemingly run out of some cubicle farm
in Pakistan raking in tons of money. I mean, this Indian guy
from Canada is out here running thousands of mega bot accounts
and people are still out here taking comment sections and likes
Thousands of mega bot accounts.
Thousands of mega bot accounts. Why Why did she just That is
like actual rage bait.
Bots are waging an online battle against progressive politicians
in the US. Okay. And people are still out here taking comment
sections and likes seriously and thinking all of this stuff going
on online is like, yeah, this is where it's at. This is we're
really having a collective psychological shift. It would be hilarious
if it weren't so absolutely
I think the truth is there's a lot of money in astroturfing certain
opinions. There is a lot of money in pacifying people with endless
content that distracts them from the real world. If you just
donate to one more fundraiser, sign another petition, hit retweet
uh or like one more time on this video. Or if you sign up for
the Patreon,
you're going to save the world. The West will be saved. Dissident
right is non-right-wing aligned politics.
And it's definitely not a rug pull crypto scam with a veneer
of activism on the front, guys. Yeah, [snorts] I hope none of
you invested in that Unite the Kingdom coin, you silly geese.
But of course, you know, I'm just above it all, aren't I, right?
I am so above it. I'm the only good one.
No, we don't think you're saying that. I think you're like not
you're you're making claims that are beyond just like your experience.
And I feel like if you're going to say all of this stuff and
then the proof is the Canadian intelligence agency or whatever,
the
tried to tried to blackmail you or extort you or tried to pressure
you into being an asset for them, that's not proof of anything
you're saying right Not at all. I have spent the last year reflecting
on how I feel I was unwittingly a cog in the machine of getting
every Not Not even entirely unwittingly. I just feel like I was
a cog in the machine of getting everyone mentally trapped in
this digital ideology farm. Not all for bad intentions, but just
little compromises here and there along the way of Oh, I just
need to, you know, if I just kind of acquiesce to what everyone
else is doing, I can still do good in my little way. But no,
the whole trajectory of the This is like somebody's telling me
that they've got like proof of a crime, basically, right? I've
I've got they've got proof of a crime. But first,
you've got to listen to my story.
You've got to listen to my story, my thoughts. It's like the
you're you're dealing with somebody who's like um in a bar or
whatever and they're drunk and they're like they're they're like
do you know that they know something interesting? There's like
something small that's interesting there, but they're like, "Hey,
you have to listen to my whole world view first." It's like,
"Damn it. Can I just give you some money? If I paid for like
That would be the best part of this, okay? I would easily pay
15, 20 dollars just to like skip to the end. Could you just give
me like the fact sheet for this? Just all of the actual facts
that you're about to lay out that aren't in the public yet. I
I would pay so much money to just skip the rest of this, right?
Not that it's not interesting. It's like fine,
but here's the thing. When I want to watch somebody who's like
got a coherent worldview or or some coherent idea to put forward,
I want it to be beyond things that like I already think or know.
And these are all things that I literally like think or know
or have like thought about already. And it's not like any new
ground broken, any new information yet. She's just like kind
of spinning this web of
I don't know, everybody. The political sphere is headed towards
brain rot, in my opinion. And I hope all of this isn't sounding
insanely schizophrenic because it's not. Mass botting, paid for
influencers, federal agents and assets, all of that is real.
And I just think it took governments and corporations time to
figure out the
Um people who have like schizophrenic rants often pull facts.
The The issue is not the facts themselves. I I I can understand
that all of the all of those facts are real. It's It's about
how they interact and weave together that's
And if you're saying like, "Oh, it's If this seems schizophrenic."
Well, it's like you're connecting things. I don't know if they're
connected yet. You have to You've got to lay that out. Like I
can I can believe this. I can even like think this is true.
But if it's all disconnected spaghetti, it's like I've seen some
of the other disconnected spaghetti. You're not contributing
something new. You're just providing more disconnected spaghetti.
>> best ways to capture the internet while making it appear
organic.
But they've done it. They've done it. Total victory. Well done.
And God help you if you try to find exactly where any of the
money or the marching orders are coming from. I mean, maybe Maybe
maybe
I I feel like the more interesting thing here would be Lauren
talking to people in real life.
And showing how like old people in real life see this stuff is
totally real. Cuz everybody who's on YouTube wanting to watch
Lauren Southern is young enough that they understand that like
botting and like botting to give people influence is like a massive
thing right now. That's like not confusing to anyone. Maybe this
video is just like way outside of my demographic. Maybe this
video is made for 50-year-old boomers who don't understand this
concept yet. 60, 70, 80-year-old boomers? Maybe this is like
if this was a Fox News segment, maybe it could do well. Maybe
you can find one or two, especially if you know these things
first hand, but
like when we talk about the majority of the chessboard, who's
real, who isn't, who's paid for, who's being blackmailed, beats
me. Because every single person is yelling grifter and fed at
everyone else. And it is purposely put together so you don't
find out.
This has always been her problem, right?
Like I I understand. I have these same
but it's like, "Okay, everybody is a possible asset of something."
Like every Maybe maybe the entire internet is paid for. But if
you If that's just your thought, maybe the entire internet is
paid for and like it's all just countries like waging war against
each other by propping up Nick Fuentes or propping up Trump's
ideas or something like that. It's like I could I could even
buy that. I just need some new piece of information that makes
that interesting, right? And also compellingly defeats some of
the other ideas that like, "Oh, the compensation for doing this
kind of grifting, for for giving people the ideas they want precisely
in in like a populist way, like that's not just monetarily beneficial
to you."
That audience capture is not doing it by itself. She's already
talked about audience capture, but I think audience capture explains
probably far more of it than she is making it seem like right
now. what's going on. It is purposely put together so it all
looks organic. And there is not one of us here who is above being
propagandized to, which is why I You probably even noticed if
you were watching my videos last year and the year before, I
put in these little things where I just kept reminding people,
"Step outside your own front door. What you see with your own
eyes The Tene speech is so uninspiring. >> and your real
tangible relationships should reign supreme every time over what
some rando on the internet tells you. And which is why I also
made the That isn't Why? Why keep I Why keep saying that?
That doesn't give credence to anything happening here. position
to spend much less time on the internet myself because this,
you know, when you stare into the abyss, the abyss stares back
into you. Internet creators are not immune from the propaganda
affecting them and then affecting the things that they say. It
could be fun sometimes, don't get me wrong. I had a blast doing
YouTube stuff. I had a blast on the internet. I grew up RuneScape,
Gaia Online, you know, League of Legends when it first came out.
Like I loved the online world and online communities, politics,
early Twitter on Tumblr. I was in part of political communities
and Cafepress and on Facebook. Like all of this stuff. I loved
it. But we took a wrong turn at effing Albuquerque after that
eight died at the zoo in 2016 or something and teetered off into
a reality where slowly the back She teetered off.
She's really not aligned. She's just doing super old references.
vast majority of the pre- It's a Harambe reference. God damn
it. just became purely a manipulation tool. And I'm sick of it.
And I'm sick of watching everyone fall for it, especially the
people who call themselves true seekers. That shouldn't be. So,
that's where I'm at right now. Let's go back to how I mentally
got here, which buckle up because we're about to take a wild
ride. Go grab yourself some tea. Things are about to go interesting
places. Q September 2024 when I disappear off
A Canadian-owned social media channel that the US Justice Department
alleges is a key part of a Russian influence scheme is now off
YouTube. Okay. Now we're going Now we're going to Tene stuff.
Maybe it'll get interesting, okay? This is the whole thing is
I was very interested in the Tene scandal and how that affected
a bunch of stuff, how people look at the internet. And I think
it'd be very interesting to
Oh, yeah. I think it'd be very interesting to get like behind-the-scenes
facts from Lauren here. I do also think though that it's very,
very interesting that Lauren feels like she's the person who's
seeing all the patterns when she is one of the only people that
we have confirmed on the record having been like sort of used
by an a national interest in this way. She's like one of the
only people that is like been totally ignorant to the fact that
she was being paid by another national interest to do this,
right? dollars in part through Lauren Southern Tene Media to
pay MAGA influencers like Dave Rubin, Benny Johnson, Tim Pool,
and Canadian Lauren Southern to spread the Kremlin's pro-Trump,
anti-Ukraine messages. Should these allegations prove true, I
as well as other personalities and commentators were deceived
deceived and are victims. I cannot speak for anyone else in the
company as to what they do or what they are instructed. The Culture
War podcast was licensed by Tene Media and existed well before
any license agreement with Tene. It will continue to exist after
any such agreement expires. Having said we still do not do not
know what is true. These are only allegations. Putin is a scumbag.
Russia sucks donkey balls. And to the journalists who wish to
jump the gun, create their own narrative, or lie about what's
currently going on, you can eat my Irish ass. I said, "Don't
do it." Did I not say, "Don't do it?" I [laughter] said, "Don't
do it." You did say, "Don't do it." You did. But let's give people
a little more detail there. It wasn't just "Don't do it." I turned
it into just a nightmare. So, you did the work, you got the money,
reportedly 5 million bucks, and the indictment that came down
of not of Lauren Chen, she hasn't been indicted, but of the people
who started this podcast network called Tene Media, are allegedly
a couple of Russians who work for RT, which used to be called
Russia Today. It's state- owned media in in Russia. Those two
have been indicted. And the interesting thing about those two
being indicted is as Andy McCarthy pointed out on his podcast,
they're ghosts. They'll never be arrested. It's basically just
a way for the DOJ to try to embarrass the conservative podcasters
who got pulled into this, even though the indictment itself makes
very clear that they had no idea they were working for the Russians.
Didn't Lauren Chen move to China or something? No. Lauren Chen's
like back on Twitter trying to do political influencing stuff.
Also, none of these people stood up at that moment in time and
said, "No, this didn't happen. No, this is fake." They're all
like, "No, I didn't really know about it." And now Now, after
I think the charges get dropped, they'll go, "Actually, no, this
is just a CIA op to like stop us all from doing influence stuff.
This is to stop us all from making videos." Shut the [__]
up, bro. You know it wasn't. You know that the facts in that
None of them ever accept or challenge or grapple with any of
the facts in that actual indictment, right? In the actual document,
the the court case that was filed, none of them ever grapple
with those actual facts or say, "No, that didn't happen."
They just go, "Oh, this is all made up. It's just made up to
[__] conservative influencers." Russians, and that
all of that maintained, except for one guy who says maybe according
to the indictment, I haven't heard this person respond to it,
but everybody says they had editorial independence, no strings
were being pulled by the Russians, by Lauren Chen, or by anybody
else. They But basically that this is the DOJ's attempt to say,
"Everyone's a Russian stooge. Conservatives are Russian stooges.
The Russians are interfering again. Don't trust conservatives.
They're Russian stooges." Am I Am I about to have it about right?
You are You do have it about right. That Well, the funny thing
to me is when this story broke, whatever it was, 10 days ago,
and I read the indictment, I'm so used to reading dishonest things
about me that when I was reading it I was like, "Oh, this actually
is all true. I knew Lauren for all these years. She told me I
was working with this French businessman. I'm commentator number
one in the indictment for people that want to read it. I'm the
one that asked for more information. They sent me what I what
I think now it says is a fake AI bio about this guy with a picture.
Maybe you guys have it over there." It looks fancy. It looks
fancy. It's not fancy. It is totally
like it's it's Nigerian prince tier.
Dave Rubin is just lying. They're both lying. But even that didn't
didn't I was like not satisfied with that. So I asked Yeah, so
that's what they sent me. How about you read it? How about you
read it and try to make sense of it? How about you look at all
the companies listed and wonder, "Hey, maybe I should look up
some of those Maybe I should call one of those companies and
say I'm checking a reference."
Did anyone think to do that? And I said, "Well, I'd like to talk
to the guy." That's what I said to Lauren. All my communications
were with Lauren and clearly the DOJ has all those communications
cuz everything in the indictment was true. Um and then they I
got on a Zoom call. Lauren set me up on a Zoom call with a person
that I was told was her French benefactor named Eduard Gregorian.
And now I don't know who I spoke to.
It was earlier that year, maybe around February, that I don't
I was just starting to have this moment of sentience, clarity
about the political sphere, that everything was unspeakably weird
to levels I couldn't just shove into deep dark corners of my
brain anymore. The obvious government op influencer trips I was
getting offered, the cash and subtle manipulation behind the
scenes in 2023 and 2024 was just picking up to degrees I'd never
seen before in my life in that space. I was getting offers to
go to Russia, Israel, Saudi Arabia, other places. Some of them
totally paid for, first class, you know, the whole shebang, wink
wink, you're going to say the things you want you to say. You
might see some people on these trips right now. I was seeing
influencers getting invented from scratch and astroturfed into
oblivion on my feed. Very obvious botting, yet institutions around
them were also supporting them. And, you know, watching elements
of the influencer world that I know for a fact are linked to
crime and are using their public facade to further it and cover
up their tracks. Okay, that Oh my goodness. There is a hard claim.
Surely there's going to be some evidence here. Surely there's
going to be something like, "Hey, she's got to name a name. She's
got to say something
For [__] sake. >> Watching them totally buy
tons of my peers behind the scenes. Just straight up, "Here's
a check. You're going to work as propaganda for us now. You're
going to say what we want you to say." And and just watching
the public fall for it in so many cases had me losing my mind.
I'm talking Wait, say a name. >> [__] full
Pepe Silvia charts on my walls trying to figure out what's going
on. And, you know, I I If you're wondering, Lauren, why weren't
you talking about this? I'm one person. I got into politics Okay,
that's fine. I Lauren, I don't care that you didn't talk about
it back then. Actually, I don't think anybody cares that you
didn't talk about it back
I'm wondering why you're not naming people now, making actual
claims, actual tangible claims, Lauren. What the when I was 19
years old. I don't I'm not a trust fund kid. I came from a working
class family. I don't have a big corporation behind me. I've
been independent for the most part. And you I I don't have the
ability to take on giant government criminal corruption entities.
And at some point I was just kind of left spiraling about this
all.
Trying to figure out what what do I do? What can I do? Do I just
accept this all? Do I just accept that the space I need to go
back. Hold on. 17:31. I need to go back.
And I'm commentator my brain anymore. The means in 2023 and 2024
was just picking up to degrees I'd never seen before in my life
in that space. I was getting offers to go to Russia, Israel,
Saudi Arabia, other places. Some of them totally paid for, first
class, you know, the whole shebang, wink wink, you're going to
say the things you want you to say. You might see some people
on these trips right now. I was seeing influencers getting invented
from scratch and astroturfed into oblivion on my feed. Very obvious
botting, yet institutions around them were also
supporting them. >> Sure. Brad Cooper. We've all seen Brad
Cooper. of the influencer world that I know for a fact are linked
to crime and are using their public facade to further it and
cover up their tracks. Watching them totally buy tons of my peers
behind the scenes. Just straight up, "Here's a check. You're
going to work as going to say what we want you to say."
And and just Lauren Southern just tipped $5.
I am righteous. I am graped. I hate browns. Give me money, please.
That's the gist of it, okay? That's the gist of it. Thank you.
I'm talking full Pepe Silvia charts on my walls trying to figure
out what's going on. I got to go back to where we were. to take
on giant government criminal corruption So she can't take any
of that on because she's just one person.
But you were out of the game. You easily could have just said
some stuff, right? It sounds like you actually should be working
as a government asset. It sounds like they knew you knew some
[__] And they were hoping you would help. And instead
you outed them. Hey, guess who Guess who can help with criminal
elements buying up influencers online?
Intelligence agencies in your government could help. And instead
you're publishing the calls you got from them. How about you
put these people on something, Lauren? How about you do some
[__]
And at some point I was just kind of left spiraling about this
all.
Trying to figure out what what do I do? What can I do? Do I just
accept this all? Do I just accept that the space is unbelievably
weird and totally being controlled and there is nothing I can
say or do about it publicly because it's just little old me.
And even, you know, it's not like the al- alternative media on
either side or mainstream media want to investigate this properly
cuz everyone's kind of getting a bit of a paycheck, right? And
everyone's got something to hide, including me. Everyone, right?
Okay, so we're in the midst of like this mental breakdown. Like
2024,
September comes around and I'm driving to my office one fateful
morning and I just feel my phone start buzzing in my pocket.
I'm like, "Man, what's going on?" I look at it, swipe, front
page of Apple News, my face there with Tim Pool, Dave Rubin,
Taylor Hanson, saying I'm a Russian asset. And the company I'm
working for are allegedly a Kremlin op.
To top this off, I go back and I read the articles after the
shock kind of initially hits. And I find out my peers are making
like millions of dollars while my dumb ass is getting a normal
wage. After production costs, I'm making like 100k. And no, nothing
about a secret Kremlin money That's not a normal wage. That's
a That's a really good >> plot or talking points was involved
in any contract I signed. Just one too many videos per week to
make anything properly thoughtful, to be honest.
I laughed. It's all I could do. I just laughed. And then uh I
think maybe the second thing I did was I went and I got all my
hard drives and I buried them in the woods. I walked out to the
woods with a shovel and I buried my hard drives. I know that
sounds really bad, but it genuinely wasn't because I had anything
to hide. If you Uh okay. Listen, I kind of believe her when she
says she had like a full-on
which like I don't I obviously don't judge for. But like I I
get the impression she might be dealing with some stuff, right?
That's what some of this is. And she's probably feeling a lot
better and she's trying to put all the pieces back together.
So from that perspective, I understand. I I'm like respectful
of that. I understand that. It's all good. But
I don't know. That was bad, okay? That was rough. who followed
me for years. You may have heard me talk about the times where
I've been arrested, detained by governments in Australia. That
was probably one of the most recent ones when I left during COVID.
They detained me and told me I wouldn't be able to see my family.
I wouldn't be able to go home unless I gave them all of my computers,
all of my devices so they could download them. This is like an
extreme violation of my privacy. And do they ever find anything?
No, they never do. It's never, "We've got the smoking gun on
Lauren. She's going to jail." That's just It's never happened.
It's like memes and my private conversations with people. Uh
it sounds like
Okay, I know this is crazy. But like hypothetically, if if it's
true that she has a whole bunch of she's noticed she's got examples
of conduct from uh like influencers accepting money from other
countries, influencers accepting
uh what else would it be? So money from other countries or money
from criminal organizations. She's been connected to these people.
Does she not think that maybe these government agencies are like
tracking her down, trying to run down those cases, and that possibly
like helping would, I don't know, help,
I Right?
I didn't want them going through my life I believe I should be
free to write cringey notes and posts about my failed romantic
life like everybody else without feds going through it, okay?
I feel I should be free to take a bad selfie without the government
having a copy, at least in my humble opinion. I was sick of having
my life violated and that was like the first kind of panic, "Oh
my gosh, this is happening all over again." Anyways, as you can
imagine, when you find yourself somehow at a point in your life
where you're frantically burying hard drives in the woods, there
is rarely an upward trajectory after this point. My job is gone
and that's like the last of my priorities or worries right now.
My san-
That should be pretty high up there. You've got people to take
care of. sanity is already wearing thin and now my spiral about
everything being weird in the space is just seemingly confirmed.
Everything was weird. I didn't know any of the details and honestly
I wasn't even trying to grapple with my speculations in that
moment. Um
what I don't even trust anything I read in the news at this point.
I've seen too much fake nonsense in that regard as well. Either
way, I retained lawyers right away, not least of all because
I was the only Tenant Media staff member in Canada and we just
simply do not have the same rights as Americans here.
And then there was also another thing, another concern that would
be way too convoluted to get into in this video. Just know that
I was concerned the feds had something on me unrelated to Tenant
and I'm not trying to hide it. It's just that if I brought it
up here without going on a 10- to 20-minute tangent after, it
would sound way worse than it actually is. I get into it all
in a book I'm going to talk about in a moment. But just Okay.
Okay, dude.
Shut up.
That's so That's Honestly, if you go through it in the book in
the same way you're doing it now, thank God that you've you've
like brought that book to my attention so I can never ever ever
buy that book. I would blow my brains out having to go through
this again. know that that concern existed in my mind as well.
Anyways, given what I expressed to my lawyers, the worries I
had, as well as the completely [clears throat] uncertain nature
of this Tenant indictment and what every newspaper is saying,
they then if we we go up to this like high-rise uh building in
Vancouver, put all our phones in a vault, and they spend 3 hours
preparing me for what an arrest might look like, essentially.
What it what it will look like if the what I should say, what
I should not say, who I should be talking to, which is basically
no one, uh how all of my friends, everyone I've worked with,
could be a rat, how, you know, this is serious business and I
need to wake up and realize that there is like
like the police might be coming and putting me in handcuffs kind
of situation. And I didn't even Like that wasn't that was kind
of this situation in my head where it's like, "No, surely that
can't be it." Because in my heart of hearts I don't think I I
don't feel I've done anything that warrants arrest or jail time
or anything like that, right? But the stuff I'm seeing online,
the stuff I'm hearing, and then the stuff my lawyers are telling
me, it's sinking in that, "Oh my gosh, this is like real real."
Okay. It is real real. And anyone who comes out and says the
tenant indictments like weren't real there's it was totally made
up or something is a [__] loser, okay? I saw I think
I've seen Shawn H.A. W do this as [__] crazy to me.
But
in any case
I don't think is she trying to say that like she's being lied
to? I feel like there's a there's a good chance you get caught
if you were helping like the mafia and you didn't realize it
you're like a patsy for the mafia. I think you're still getting
trouble. Like if you if you're running like a business for the
mafia you don't realize it's for the mafia and they're using
it to launder cash or something you are like you are helping
with a
I I if it comes down to like a judgment call on how much you
knew I don't know man like you might still end up going to court
going to jail.
I which uh I I don't think that's crazy. As you can imagine after
being told I may be getting arrested potentially that was super
helpful for my nervous system while I stared at the ceiling every
night until 3:00 a.m. for like weeks between deleting thousands
of kill yourself Russian comments on my Instagram page and YouTube
wondering what the local moms in my community would think if
they saw me. I'm just trying to go about my day-to-day normal
life making pancakes in the morning drives to school like
and and I trying to gauge how
how effed I am. I guess CNN had reported that Lauren Southern
was an alias for Lauren Chen when this all happened.
See that's the kind of thing where I'm like dude dude what?
You know that's not true and that's not actually discrediting
CNN in some way and they would have updated that and reported
that that was like false. They would have issued a correction.
Right? Like that's not a that's not proof of anything. That's
not proof of anything. Getting one tiny totally irrelevant adjacent
fact wrong is not proof that CNN is like an op working against
you. It's not. I don't know where they got that. Anyways a ton
of people thought I was the company owner so that was really
And that just kind of exacerbated a lot of the hate mail that
I was getting and articles and posts and this and that once again
Where? Where did people think that you were the owner of tenant?
Just everything is wrong. That that I feel like is totally
like I would bet money that that did not happen in any at any
substantial level at all. I think that is total cope right there.
No everything is wrong. Doesn't matter if they're CNN doesn't
matter if they're dissident media random YouTube skits or posts
no information seems to be correct and even if it is it's largely
missing enough context that doesn't even matter anymore. We've
entered just this absurdism where everything is happening so
fast that unless you're making tons of mistakes in your reporting
you cannot keep up. While this is going on every major newspaper
outlet in America seems to get my phone number. I'm getting calls
from the Associated Press from the New York Times. I guess everyone's
just handing my phone number out and constantly nope nope saying
no trying to act normal deleting them all every day waiting for
the other shoe to drop. Sorry I can't talk to you biggest news
networks in America I'm trying to do legal That's not rage bait
that's how Canadians say sorry, okay? >> with my kid and
wait to see if I'm getting arrested and eventually the other
shoe does drop. I'm having a regular dinner and I hear a knock
at the door and I don't think much of it. I I kind of I've entered
this space of okay surely surely nothing's going to happen. You're
hyping this up in your brain Lauren. Open the door and there's
the police with two a man and woman in like leather jackets black
outfits that bring out a badge that says CSIS
which is our like FBI CIA equivalent in >> Here we go.
the local police force to confirm that they weren't just people
posing as agents they were real agents and I I needed to talk
to them. Hey can we have a conversation with you Lauren? I immediately
go into panic mode you know? Um I have a pretty tough constitution
when it comes to this kind of stuff because I've had a lot of
time in questioning rooms in my life in various different countries
getting detained at borders. It I've usually found it largely
entertaining you know what can you guys really do to me? I know
I've done nothing wrong. But I've never had it happen in my own
home or in Canada so my stomach was definitely doing a few flips.
And you know when I had that conversation with the lawyers in
the hallway they just told me do not
>> Don't do it. Call just call us you know when when they
come if that happens. So I'm immediately trying to call my lawyers
and I cannot get a hold of them and the the feds come in and
they're like okay we're going to we're just going to sit down
on the deck and you're saying you won't talk to us. Nope I'm
not saying anything to you. We'll talk to you. We'll talk at
you because you're going to want to hear what we have to So I
sit I'm listening trying to get a hold of my lawyers and
apparently they've been following me for a bit even before the
indictment. Uh they knew a lot about my life. They they literally
were like we know you've had bad experiences with feds before
but we're not like other feds. I'm not joking. We're not like
other feds. Uh they had favorite videos of mine they'd watched
they opined about my family dynamics personal files how good
I was at hiding where I lived.
Every meme I've ever sent over the last decade about imagine
if the feds read this chat haha
like just significantly became less funny you know? If my schizo
theories were starting to weigh heavy on me before about you
know the space being weird everything being controlled and watched
and this and that uh now all of my most schizophrenic thoughts
were standing on my doorstep flesh and blood. What one does with
that I don't know I don't know. I spent the next few months being
incessantly harassed by one of these federal agents who was resolute
that my life would be over if I didn't become an informant for
them on not just the tenant media stuff but the political space
in general the dissident political world and they told me you
know that that day after they met I'm Okay so not just that seemed
to me to say we don't just want you to inform on right? We want
you to inform on all like right wing politics. That's what they
want. Which is a bit interesting. I don't know if that's
Maybe maybe. That would I could see how that would fuel if she
already was thinking hey I think all politics is bought. I think
all of this is like fake it's all national interests or criminal
interests who are buying this up and getting people to do stuff.
I do understand how oh suddenly the feds are like also you need
to inform on your other influencer friends. It's like oh Jesus
like they they must actually think this is a bigger problem.
I'm like yeah I'm not talking to you and they're like you know
speak to your lawyers and you need to talk to us again we'll
be waiting at a cafe in your town But then if you think that
I don't understand like to me
to me I feel like you got to go okay the government's the only
people who could possibly be on my side here.
Isn't isn't that the case? The government has to be the only
people who could possibly be on your side. Everyone else is gone.
It's just like I don't know why you're not going to the government
in the first place if you think all this stuff's going on if
you have evidence of it going on. But to me it sounds like she
was talking about it earlier I don't know what evidence she
Like Brett Cooper well concerning Brett Cooper being invented
is like not um
like one I think people already think that but two I'm not sure
that that's like I'm just not sure that that's proof of quite
as much as you're saying but I take a lot of convincing on stuff
like this so We'll keep going. We'll see you there. We'll see
you there.
woke up the next morning and just thought maybe if I don't go
they'll disappear. I don't I don't know. I'm not I'm not going
though. I'm not going to this cafe. I remember it like hitting
10:00 and my heart pounding being like I'm not walking through
that door. I'm not walking through that door. Is is everything
going to be fine? And then it was for like a few days. They I
didn't they don't like call you or leave notes. They try not
to leave traces of themselves, right? So that I didn't hear anything
and then I start you know I'm thinking maybe they'll call you
or leave notes. They try By call you I mean contact you from
an official number or give you a card or something clarifying
because I talk about them because I'm about to talk about anonymized
calls, okay? >> traces of themselves, right? So that I
didn't hear anything and then I start you know I'm thinking maybe
I'm getting back into my normal life routine here and then I
start getting all these calls on my phone from a random number.
And it's not like a regular scam number like it keeps calling
over and over. Usually the scam callers will call like once or
twice and then give up after you hung up. And then when I definitely
knew it wasn't just a random scammer was it started turning into
signal calls. Signal is like the encrypted app um for chatting
and these calls are
over and over and over again and I spend a few days just reject
reject reject trying to figure out what the number is.
I think I can't remember maybe I blocked one and it there was
another one that started. I don't know. I can't remember. I have
to I have to go look back. I would literally just tell them like
I don't know why she didn't just say like hey just so you know
I'm going to need you to call me from like official government
numbers. We have a pre a prefix in Canada for official government
numbers.
Like official government numbers will always call you from the
same prefix.
Hey go to a government place call me from a government prefix
make sure I can dial back into your government prefix because
every office in the government has a way to dial into certain
people in the office.
Hey why don't you just do that for me? So I can know who you
are. I could go at some >> a few days in oh I tried to
call it back from a different number and there was no answer
and like no name on the the other end of the line or whatever.
And then it starts turning into text message text messages that
say you know hey you need to talk to me. Sorry brief audio insert
to get this right. We have this text exchange where I'm basically
like I don't know who the hell you are and he responds to me
saying we spoke on your patio a bit ago. I put together that
it's the feds. We have a brief call where he says he needs to
see me in person has something very important to tell me. I tell
him no talk to my lawyers and then this happens and you know
I'm still ignoring this until my gym call me and tell me there
is someone that rang them looking for me named
And they're like do you have like an ex-boyfriend that's stalking
you? Should we be worried? What's going on? And they they said
they really need to talk to It just hits
me like if I keep ignoring what what I
Oh [__] Hold on. Give me a second. I just had a I
just had a realization of my own. named Jason. Um and they're
like do you have like an ex-boyfriend that's stalking you? Should
we be worried? What's going on? And they they said they really
need to talk to It just hits me like if I keep ignoring what
what I think this text message and all these calls are they're
just going to start getting more involved in my life in my day-to-day
life. They're going to show up in places I don't want them to
show up where I have like I don't want my community I don't know
I don't want normal people in my life knowing about this insanity
going on. Not least of all cuz my lawyers are telling me don't
tell
Like disappear. Just basically disappear because they're I mean
one of the things they mentioned is that this might just be a
total political show and they need a fall guy right now and you
don't want to make yourself a target. So just lay
And anyways the conversation continues and I'm You've been showing
the text? No she's not shown any like evidence that I've seen
so far. She just shows like calls she shows like excerpts of
calls, >> filling this position of I'm not saying anything
I'm not talking to you talk Now hold on hold on I should say
it does seem like the Canadian government was implying you should
be a informant for us cuz that seems like you you could get in
a lot of trouble if you don't. That seems very real. That seems
like totally true, probably.
But it's way different than a lot of the other stuff she's she's
talking about. I just want to I'm going to watch and see if there's
like a big disconnect between these things. >> Look at
me. They tell me or he tells me, "You're in a lot of trouble,
Lauren. Um I'm trying to help you." You like This is now now
he's called and I finally picked up. I What was expressed to
me was that the rest of this department, I guess, like in CSIS,
they've decided to throw me to the wolves. Those are the words
he used on the phone. And he out of the kindness of his heart,
he's reaching out because he wants to do a little side quest
to save me from the rest of the organization who have given up
on me. Throw to the wolves, it's over for her. Her life's going
to be over. Um but if you Is she Is she confused about good cop
bad cop? Does she Does she think this is something other than
them trying to do good cop bad cop on her?
Hey, I know these guys are really bad. It's like it's very clear
what's happening. What is the confusing element? If you talk
to me, I I told them I can still turn you. You know, I can still
get you to work for us with us, whatever. So I'm doing you a
real favor here, Lauren, and then you got to I'm coming out again
and and we're going to have a chat. I'm like, "I'm not talking
to you. I'm not I don't I don't even know what you want from
me. All I know is legally I'm not supposed to talk to you right
now and none of this feels good. None of this feels right. I
don't know what's happening right now." Anyways, the the main
message that has been conveyed to me is I'm in a I'm in big trouble
if I don't work with them. I eventually conclude I simply don't
know what their motives are. I don't know what's going on right
now. I don't know if they're trying to entrap me. I don't know
what's real anymore in the news or in this whole like subterranean
fed level nonsense going on. So I figured the one thing I know
in the political world is that if you don't have something recorded,
everyone will lie through their teeth about what actually happened.
I have seen the most shocking lies about me, the most shocking,
blatant rewriting of history. And in a situation where I'm being
threatened with jail or who knows Wait, where? I with no I I
Does she understand with with no like What is the lie? What are
you talking about? You're just you're basically just wishcasting
right now. Like you're you're creative writing. I have no way
to connect any of this to reality. And you're telling me that
you are having breaks from reality while expecting me to just
believe all of this story. It's like if you could show me what
you mean, it would help a lot. You don't You don't even have
to By the way, most editors will do it this way, right? You can
keep monologuing, but as you're going through, as you're talking
about specific pieces of evidence, if they were just flashing
up on screen, that would be infinitely more helpful and trustable.
spending the rest of my life as this little government asset
rat. It's just too big of a situation to not record my own. So
I I actually I I take this and I clip it to the inside of my
bra under a shirt before they came back or this this guy came
back. I was like nearly puking. So nervous that it would go off
cuz they're like, you know, "Let's see your phone. Make sure
you're not recording. Shut it off." kind of thing. "We're going
to have a conversation." But it is a one-party consent in Canada.
So my goodness, I hope I'm fine on that level at this point.
I feel like I've been through so much chaos with the police,
feds, this, that. It's just like, "What What next?" I don't I
don't even If they want to send me to jail, it's it would have
happened by now, I feel. So whatever. Anyways, Jason comes back
to see me.
we go on this long walk in the woods, conversation about
You know, there's there's a chance Don't you want to be around
to Don't you want to be around to see your son grow up? All right,
a couple things before you listen to these recordings. One, I
have a nervous laughter response. So just because I'm laughing
does not mean I'm having a good time. I was, you know, in hysterics
when I thought I was going to jail in Turkey. Two, why don't
you just work for them, Lauren? My lawyers have told me, "Do
not speak to the feds. They are not your friends. If anything,
they're trying to catch you saying something stupid even if you
didn't do anything wrong because they may just be putting on
a show, child. This may be a political thing. They may just be
wanting to find a fall guy because they've made a whole show
of this
So you say to them, you negotiate through your lawyer, "Hey,
I have information that would be helpful to you, but I'm not
going to give it to you without an immunity deal. You just grant
me immunity blanket from like any of the the crimes around this
stuff." And I Is that all just obvious?
Like literally it's just Hey, you talk to your lawyer. You say,
"Here's the things I know. You figure out a way to say like hypothetically,
you know, in a video game, she might know some things around
these things. And if you want to give her an immunity deal, then
she could talk to you about them." It's like
Uh okay. We'll keep going. >> they get you wrapped up in
courts for years and years having to prove this was just a stupid
thing I said in an interview where this guy was pretending to
be my friend. So Like nobody's saying you have to talk to them
alone without a Nobody's saying that. Zero people are saying
that. >> This is not It's Nothing that you're listening
to here is as simple as it seems. Three, I have there's hours
of recordings. I've just cut up a bit here uh to show you give
you kind of a flavor of what was going on and what I was dealing
with for months. All right. Here you go. Wait. Just start I just
want to ask you please can I just turn off the phone? Oh, yeah.
We're I'm really trying to be here to help you and navigate you
out of this because if you just sit here and don't do anything,
I know that's the easiest thing for your lawyer to say, but your
lawyer's not going to be the one sitting in the detentions. Like
you you That happened to you a bunch of times. I know You You're
actually the You put up a very amazing front that things don't
just disturb you and it's it's quite actually incredible. Okay,
is this guy Is this guy like trying to
Maybe Maybe this guy just knew that Lauren Southern was single
at this point, okay?
Is that Is that all we Is that all we're watching here? Is this
guy like continually using his position position to try to rizz?
Like when we came to your door, maybe you had 10 seconds of nervousness.
It's obviously I Still, it's obvious that it's good cop bad cop.
Like, "Oh, you I'm You're You're actually really You're actually
really kind and all." It's just good cop bad cop, but You're
selling yourself out and you're calm and quiet and that is actually
in in another light, you would have made a really intelligent
move.
I know. It comes out. It comes out and it does stress you out
and it it should because you're you're you're main One of your
primary jobs is you're you're also a mother and besides your
other job. As a mother, you want to be there. You want to uh
protect your kid. You want to be there seeing him grow up. You
want to You also you want to be there to be able to provide for
him cuz you're doing like a lot of multi-roles. I don't want
to I don't want to see where a situation where that gets into
your whatever you want to say. Well, that's why I Hold on. >> $3.
He pulled out his C wrist. Oh, [__]
Okay. C wrist. CS CSIS C wrist. Okay. Like I I You know a little
bit. A little bit, Reuben Reuben. I I get it. I get where you're
going. Here, I'm going to knock this down to what? 3 hours or
so?
Three
Yeah, 2:45. Okay. That's where we are on the stream. Sorry, I
was just I was not paying attention. Thank you very much for
the money, Reuben Reuben, for the donation. Appreciate it, buddy.
This doesn't sound like Maybe
Maybe I can understand how you think this is a threat.
It doesn't sound like a threat yet.
We'll We'll keep listening. I'm asking. >> So this is a
threat. >> This is actually not a threat. This is like
our second time coming. It doesn't happen often. And uh once
that legal ball gets rolling, when Lauren or CSIS partners you,
there's nothing they can do about it then. And that's fact. I
know you think I can see you thinking when you're you're writing
your notes and trying to get ahold of your lawyer. I know we
have a very aggressive to show up at your door, but I think we
can help you navigate you. And again, my opinion, just doing
nothing is not going to get you in a better spot. It's going
to be putting you at a significant disadvantage. Nothing might
happen. You know, like nothing. If they're like, "Oh, we don't
have no significant case against against Southern." then nothing.
But if they go, "These guys are all saying negative things."
Again, when you're in a like the courtroom, it's the perception.
It's not what the truth is. And you're smart enough to know I'm
really trying to actually help you get my You're smart enough
to know what? Why did that just jump? not what the truth is.
And you're smart enough to I'm really trying to actually help
you Uh that feels rough to me that it jumps there. That feels
really rough to me
that it jumps there. No, no, no. Sorry, good cop bad cop. Cops
have already talked to her. He's trying to be good cop right
now.
But I don't I feel like it's impossible for me to separate this
guy from like legitimate like trying to get her to help it as
a cop saying like, "Hey, nothing could happen, but like I'm just
telling you it would really help. It would help you a lot if
like it would help to guarantee yourself your your safety a lot,
you know, your security a lot if you helped us out."
Also, I'll be real. If Lauren Southern were some kind of hardened
criminal, it seems incredibly obvious to me that he's got nothing
and he's just making it really clear without meaning to. Like
if I were a criminal and I were listening to this, I'd be like,
"Oh, you you ain't got [__] I'm I'm shut the [__]
up. You ain't got [__] brother. I can tell. I can
tell. You haven't mentioned anything. You haven't mentioned anything
specific. You say things might just go away. You You ain't got
nothing. I'm I'm home free." My My mom was a single mom. You're
a single mom. And I understand what you're doing right now. You're
kind of keeping low until you think that this is over. But I
want to tell you like you're saying thing for motion right now.
This is not Like this is not going away anytime soon. This Like
why What is the benefit for you cooperating is purely self-preservation.
Out of all the contributors and the founders, like all of them
have talked to you at the the the FBI. Mhm. And the only person
that's not
is you, Lauren. Like the optics of it. You don't uh Southern,
do not cooperate. What I'm getting to, the point I'm getting
to is like how how much can you trust your other commentators?
That's They are not cannibalizing each other. So she [snorts]
went and she's turned up on them and they're pointing them. Well,
I love Let me back up to from our last meeting. A lot of people
who associate with my colleagues, they're like, "All right, she
doesn't want to cooperate." I feel like this guy doesn't believe
that Lauren didn't do
Right? He He probably thinks she did like a little bit of something.
Like maybe she knew maybe more information will come out. And
he's like kind of kind of trying to bluff. But she's sitting
there like, "No, I am just a complete I was taking this money.
I had no idea what was going on here at all."
Should be fired. He does really suck at
Him talk to the feds confirmed. He's just He's clearly just trying
to like get her to cooperate with them to give them more information
cuz they suspect there's something more going on here and she
doesn't want to talk to them. That's all that's happening. I
don't know that this is like evil. I don't think I don't even
know that the threats are threats. He might legitimately be saying
like, "Hey, uh these are the thing He was also saying, "You're
concerned about these things." I don't know, he might have been
trying to empathize.
It doesn't feel like he's harshly threatening her. He's saying,
"Hey, they might have turned on you. There might be bad things
happening. Like, you should talk to us so we can get your ideas
your your your proof on the record. Sorry, your your statements
on the record so that when we hear those things, one, we know
that they're lying." Like, he could just explain this, right?
And it could be true that he's saying all these things. Right?
Like, "Hey, it's actually important you talk to us cuz they might
have tried to, you know, point the finger at you." That can all
be real.
It's confirmed that this guy is a government agent. Uh I don't
know if it's confirmed yet. I don't see who this could possibly
be other than a government agent, to be honest with you. If it
was some kind of troll, if it was somebody I like with her in
some way,
why would there have been nothing mentioned about it? Like, what
do you think if it's not a government agent?
Then then she's just correct about everything and there's some
insane conspiracy going on because apparently she met this guy
when he came to the door with the local police, right? Or she's
just like lying and she made this up. It's like one of those
two things.
>> Listen, I'm not going to throw her off to the wolves.
I'm going to just let her. I don't think you fully understand
the picture of how the front is up north uh or completely. You
can on the ground. Do you trust these people?
Do you trust him, fool? I'm just They have nothing they can say.
That's the thing. Yeah, [laughter] but what would they say?
>> They can undo the work. And that's all you really In
this kind of In this kind of case, that's all you really can
do.
So, I got to ask, when you do the uh single mom story, how you
feeling, Lauren? Do you practice that like in a room with colleagues
or do they >> No, we're actually really normal people.
Dude, I don't believe she I I straight up don't believe she's
intimidated at all. I'm sorry.
No, she can see it just as transparently as we do, right? Like,
she can see it's super obvious to her, too. I don't believe that
she thinks she's really like being into She's like, "Dude, you're
like totally unbelievable right now. You're like actually you're
just a [__] goof."
half mom and dad. Multiple ones for multiple scenarios.
>> But I'm just saying if certain things are immune, they
can't be stopped. I'll make sure that you're not like Here, hold
on.
if certain things are immune, they can't be stopped. Certain
things are emotion they can't be stopped. >> that you're
not like or the collateral damage thing. Why doesn't anyone know
anything about it?
I had to find out, research and do more digging on it to like
really understand I agree with him. And this idea of peace, you
want peace, I understand that. I'm here to help you. Wait, can
I call my gym? Oh, the gym was a You don't have to call your
gym. Should I call my gym? I cannot believe you. >> You
have to tell me. No, no, you don't [laughter] have to tell me.
I promise you this, okay? Yeah. Okay, at the conclusion of this,
let's say we do work together, at the conclusion of this, I'll
let you We get attributed to you. Your audience never know that
you provide this information. I I There's another clear cut there.
The The cuts are are messing with me. I hope she releases the
full thing.
The cuts are really really really messing with me in terms of
building up this idea that she was being like threatened like
objectively or overtly. You'll be kept anonymous. All I would
say is uh this information was provided. Uh I didn't even think
to say this, Jacob, but this this kind of true, okay?
The first thing he said to her was, "Could you turn your phone
off?"
And instead she's recording via her
Uh boy. And all the side benefit >> Wonder where she learned
the tech. >> Good stuff. That would never ever be written
as in we help smooth things over uh from prosecution or with
the FBI, all that stuff. Never. Only assurance we ever could
provide you. Well, then so once again, we're back at the Okay,
so no one knows I I There's just a big jump there. >> prosecution
or with the FBI, all that stuff ever be written as in we help
smooth things over uh from prosecution or with the FBI, all that
stuff. Never. Only assurance we ever could provide you. Well,
then so once again, we're back at the Okay, so no one knows that
I did something that doesn't benefit me at all and may even harm
me because I've got a government that's politicizing the
I talk to people in different situations and they ask me the
same thing like if I betray my country like other people from
foreign I betray my country, what assurance is that I would have
that Canada is going to vouch for me or Canada is going to pay
me X amount of dollars. Canada is going to accept me as a Canadian
citizen. And I'm like, this is [__] trust. That's
it. >> Yeah, and how many people were swinging from bridges
after being translators
by the Taliban after the Americans pulled out or in Vietnam?
Left on those >> You're absolutely right.
>> I'm not When we work with people, it it it's is never
a perfect situation. Bro, I also
What? He is so bad at his job.
Dude, my country's intelligence agencies are a
This guy's doing such terrible work right now. He's not even
believable. And then she's like, "Hey, what protections would
I have?" And he's like, "We ain't We can't protect you at all.
You're actually totally if you ever get exposed. Yeah, we can't
do [__] Yeah, we won't even talk to other countries
like their agencies and help you out. Like, we will we literally
won't do [__] for you." Like, well, what? Wait, can
you Is that even true that you wouldn't do anything? Why the
[__] you just sitting here like, "Yeah, we're we're
actually going to totally [__] you over. Yeah, we
don't care about you at all. We're Yeah, [__] you."
Um but we can help people and I have helped people. And again,
this is like a opportunity for you to walk through that door
if should you want to. I know you're very cynical on the whole
thing and we can take it one step at a time and just start slow.
And should RCMP one day come knocking, again, that is already
too late. Are you able to see it? Uh start a relation or stop
start Okay, couple things here, guys. First, I'm going to do
the first show of the day. I believe we are seven subs from another
hour on the stream. All right, seven subs from another hour.
If you guys like the content, you go ahead, sub, donate. Any
Any way you sub or donate goes to more times in the stream More
time in the stream. Also, I lied, six subs because we had the
$5 donation via the Hillary Clinton voice for Lauren Southern.
Thank you very much to that donator. Okay? So, six subs from
another hour on the stream. I also need to say that I'm going
to end the Twitch stream, go over to Kick only. So, thank you
very much for watching on Twitch, but I'm going to head over
to Kick. All right, we'll talk to you guys later. Bye-bye. Wait,
actually, no, I lied to you. I'm going to keep going. I'm going
to keep going on Twitch. I'm going to do this whole thing on
Twitch. Okay? I've just I've called an audible in my own brain.
I'm going to keep going on Twitch, actually. Keep watching on
Twitch if you're there. I'm going to keep it going. I'm going
to hit I'm going to hit play and I'll be right back. Give the
sub to your favorite family member. You could do that. All right?
I just want to start I don't want to miss the first show cuz
sometimes I get to like the end of the stream and I'm not shilling
enough and then I just like it's only whoever's watching then,
okay? So, I'll just throw it out now. If you guys like the content,
go ahead, throw a couple subs my way. Donate through the {exclamation
point} donate link, okay? There's Streamlabs, there's Kickbot.
I'm going to hit play. I'll be right back. I'm just going to
use the bathroom and then we're going to continue on with the
content. cooperating because you're already considered to be
uh Yeah, but if you don't impact the RCMP at all, then Oh, no.
And we we can't. But when they get their ball rolling, we are
we we don't we are not involved in any criminal prosecution.
Do you understand? But should we vouch for Southern, she's No,
she's good. They'll be okay. The conversation is just so vague
though. It's just like these weird vague threats of there's big
trouble around the corner, Lauren. This this tenant thing, it's
not even just about tenant. It's so much bigger and you're going
to get wrapped up in it all and we're going to be the only ones
that can protect you and it's now or never cuz if I leave and
you don't like agree to be this like informant,
it's over. This is your last chance. Like I said, the whole department,
they've given up on you. I'm I'm your last hope here. And it
Hold on, I'm back. Wait, I I'm just kind of confused.
I don't understand. She says at the very beginning of this, "I
know about corporations, governments, and criminal enterprises
basically or or cults." No, it's corporations, governments, and
cults that run certain influencers. She says that. Okay? That
sounds kind of crazy. I know there's like some amount of it that
wouldn't be crazy. But it it's like without evidence it sounds
crazy. The closest thing she has to evidence for this that I've
seen so far is this guy saying there are other investigations,
not just from this intelligence agency, but the RCMP and from
US officials, right?
That's the closest Why is she acting like that guy isn't giving
her the most like all of her credibility right now? Like, the
fact that he wants you as an informant and he's saying there's
other things coming. That's I understand he's kind of schizo
posting, too, but you have to understand that
in in a lot of ways, that guy's the thing that giving you the
most credibility on that front until you give any names or any
like actual tangible things that are happening. It just we go
between this like
Uh Sophia, thank you very much for the five gifts. Five gifted
subs, really appreciate it. We are just one sub away from another
hour on the stream. Let's go. Thank you very much, Sophia. I'm
your friend. I'm here to help. And these just vague threats that
were just messing with my head. I have this absurd night. We're
on the beach. I remember I'm just chain smoking. Like, moonlight
splitting the ocean, waves.
My fed is asking me about my non-existent dating life. He's saying
your signal profile photo looks so pretty. Is it your Tinder
profile or >> Dude. Uh dude. Uh dude.
I said it and I like kind of took it back. I didn't stand on
it, okay? That
That guy is brother. This is your job. That's not good. He's
already In the morning, he's already asked me to go out for dinner
that night. Often Wait, didn't she already kind of get honey
potted by one intelligence official from
He's just like, "Listen, I'm an Asian intelligence official in
Canada. Let's Let's run it back. Let's run it back, >> clock,
too. I say absolutely This is just like a weird side thing going
on as well. I say absolutely not, you know, fool me once, shame
on you. But this guy is is talking about feds need to eat, too.
Trying to Trying to build up this rapport constantly. You must
how how are you emotionally feeling Lauren? How are you dealing
with this? How's your personal life? >> Is there a dating
scene here?
No. Dude, the what? Wait, she's got it recorded? No.
Oh, this guy's getting blown up. This guy's getting put on blast
in front of the whole world.
>> Never mind. This went from See, this is why I don't
This is why I don't stop the video sometimes. Hey, maybe eventually
we get to some content. Boom, there it is. Let's go. Is my application
still like
middle aged and old? It'd be very hard for me to date. Well,
yeah.
>> I I assume there must I see young people now. Bro.
How do you think the other feds at the office are reacting to
this one? Well, it only got published 2 hours ago, so I'm not
sure that they're reacting to it yet at all. I Either this was
planned in front of whatever investigation happened, or I feel
like they're going to start looking into this like, dude, were
you trying to [__] inform him? The [__]
is that about?
We'll see. Maybe it was a explicit honey pot operation, okay?
Maybe he'll save himself there.
You have your profile for your signal. Is that on your dating
profile? No, I don't have a dating profile. The The one where
you're like this on the
On a train? I don't have a dating
>> Is your profile No, my friend just took that photo of
me a few weeks ago. That looks like a dating profile. Oh gosh.
picture. You got a lot of >> Maybe I should change that.
It's It's fine. I just I look happy in that picture. So you So
I got a dating profile picture. I don't I don't It's a good picture.
It's a [laughter] good picture.
>> Dude, the single mom thing now to me is sounding like
he's like Yeah, it's real hard to raise a kid by yourself. It's
real hard
to raise a kid by yourself, okay? Hit the soundboard. What soundboard?
That one? I don't even know what soundboard you guys want at
this point, but this is rough. This is really really
really rough. Listen, it's it's hard to raise a kid by yourself.
Is that your dating profile picture?
Man, I'm just I'm sitting here with like a stable government
job and and just nobody to take care of.
>> happy. Oh. You look happy. I know I always catch you
and like I always surprise you and like a
you have like this nervous [__] But you look happy
in that. You look very happy.
It's a beautiful night. It's a very interesting night. Dude.
Dude.
As she cuts off there, it's a beautiful night. And then she cuts
it off. Uh-huh.
Does she underst- She has to understand. Somebody else had to
have listened to this and just given her like, you know that
guy's like absolutely just trying to [__] you, right?
Like there's just nothing else happening there.
>> Hold on. You look happy in that. It's a beautiful night.
It's a very interesting It's a beautiful night. Hold on, are
they like in a canoe? >> You have like this nervous [__]
But you look happy >> Oh no, they're on the beach. They're
literally on the beach while they're having this conversation.
That's what that is, right? By the way, Lauren shouldn't publish
this. That gives a lot of way about where she is, but they're
on the or I nothing she can do now. They're on the beach somewhere
in BC. Right? >> happy in that. You look very happy in
Why are they on the beach? Because you can hear the waves coming
in. And I believe Lauren said they were on the beach. She was
like, we're on the beach when we had this conversation. Here,
hold on. I'll I'll go back find it in the transcript real quick.
Hold on. Hold on.
Beach. I have this absurd night. We're on the beach. I remember
I'm just chain smoking. Like moonlight splitting the ocean waves.
That was 2 minutes ago.
Next. It's a beautiful night. It's a very interesting night.
Yeah.
>> Did you write a book on >> You'd be my first buyer,
I'm sure. Dude.
She She's blowing this guy up and he's the one who gave her the
idea to write the book. What the [__] Lauren? What
the [__] It's kind of crazy how much uh I mean how
much I know about your content. I mean how much I know about
you. Do you like to have
Do you like a glass of wine at night? I don't know if you guys
can hear it. I
>> Hit the hit the vine boom. Yeah, it's really the old
school vine boom is actually what's appropriate here, okay?
I'm not much of a drinker. You're not much of a drinker. No.
You're very different from your sister. Yeah, definitely. >> What
I was looking into my sister part of your job, too. >> No,
I'm looking at every li- He's like seeing this as threats and
this is the
intelligence a intelligence agents intelligence agent that's
ever existed and he's trying to rizz and she's like, what are
you trying to You saying you can send my sister to prison, too?
And he's like, no, I'm just trying to show interest in you. level.
I'm being just psychologically f- >> Uh that's who this
is, yeah. >> And just constantly this repetition. You're
going to regret it, Lauren. You're going to regret it. This is
your last chance to comply. But every time we spoke and met up,
I kept being told it's my last chance. She's getting stalked
by like the incel intelligence agent,
The incel intel guy.
Incel intel intel down tremendous right
She's just getting stalked by a dude who's become obsessed with
her, is clearly like in love, and she
she's sitting here like, there's no way. There's no way to make
sense of this
>> except except that they're trying to they're trying
to take my life away from me. They're trying to intimidate me.
Also from your end, will you get us out of your [__]
hair and not like hanging out at your place all the time or I
thought this was the last time we were going to come by. Well,
no. We have to continue this investigation. Do you understand
what I'm saying?
Not really.
If If I don't, it's over for me and I didn't. I kept saying no.
I even was like, okay, so you guys are going to send me to jail.
What happens? I work for you guys, you give me immunity to whatever
this is. Oh no, we can't give you immunity, but we might be able
to We might be able to soften things up, Lauren. We might be
able to make sure, you know, if if you're you we can get your
travel situation worked out. We can talk to the FBI and make
sure they're not going to do anything to you anymore. If if there
are like these big charges that come through towards you, we
can if you're working with us, just know it's going to be a better
situation for you, right? Every time we meet up, I'm just being
told like this is my last chance. It's over for me, but I kept
seemingly getting last chances every time I say said no to them.
Uh but they keep kept coming back, kept calling, just trying
to build up this like relationship rapport. And once again, I
don't I don't even know what they want. I don't even know what
the threat is. I There isn't a threat, but we all know what they
want, Lauren. It's very very very obvious what they want. >> Am
I going to jail? What did I do wrong? There is this thing at
the back of my head about this other concern I had and I don't
know if they know about it. I don't know if this is the threat,
but um eventually it wasn't until later that I found out that
that was fine and I didn't actually do anything wrong, but that's
also at the back of my head that, oh my gosh, they may seriously
have something on me. Um either way, in retrospect, all of this
going on, some of you are probably already thinking that Lauren
a lot of the things they're saying to you are just psychological
manipulation tactics to get you to cave and comply. It all felt
very real when I was in it, though. Like I get that. Looking
back,
it makes sense. You know, a lot of the things they said to me
obviously weren't true. It's a year later and they were saying
I'd never be able to travel to America. He's trying to build
a friendly rapport with her. What would he do differently? I
don't know. Probably not
This might seem creepy, but your sister drinks a lot. I got I'm
sorry. That is weird. That is a weird thing to say in any Where's
the rapport building? Um
your sister drinks a lot, eh? It's what? Are you talking about?
>> again, that wasn't true. They're telling
you know, there's going to be this big like essentially actual
arrest, like the handcuffs kind of arrest that might happen.
The charges, everything. None of this came to fruition, right?
Uh But when when you're in it, it's like very real, you know?
I've I'm not talking to anyone else. My lawyers have told me
not to talk to people about this. My friends and family No, not
all of them. I I have some really good people in my life, but
there are good friends of mine that have started distancing themselves,
co-workers and peers because of all the chaos going on in the
media. And on top of this, I got this fed telling me that my
peers and friends are talking to them. That I was the only one
holding out out of the tenant crew. And do you know how that
makes you look, Lauren? Some of the other stuff that your former
colleagues are are saying. Like it can be completely irrelevant
at the end of the day. Mhm.
But we need something to like Yeah, but you say that as as if
I'm worried about anything that they're saying. I'm not. You
look happy You [laughter] look happy. As if I need to I'm really
not. Another note from the editor's desk. Do you see what's going
on there? He's told me before, it doesn't matter what truth is,
Lauren. It matters what perception is. It doesn't matter what
the other commentators are saying. It doesn't matter if
Yeah. I I understand. So there's two things there. It's like
you could perceive that as a threat that he's saying you'll get
[__] no matter what. He also might be just trying
to be like, oh, she actually did something. I think she did something.
I think she has information. I'm just going to bluff. I don't
know. It's It doesn't It just the the idea that it's like a threat
of we'll make [__] up and it won't matter and you'll
just go to jail. Like that's obviously not true. I understand
a cop trying to say it's true, right? An interrogator or a cop
trying to trying to get information out of somebody might say
it's true, but it's obviously not. If it's horse [__]
what matters is who's talking >> And she The thing is is
she clearly identifies that it's not a problem. She says as much
to him directly. Yeah, I haven't done anything, so I'm not worried
about it.
talking first. So we need something from you. We need you to
say something for us so we can go after them instead of making
you the fall guy. And of course, I'm saying I don't care. I'm
not
I'm not about to show a federal agent that I'm panicking a bit
inside, which I am, because I don't know if they're just about
to make up a fake case against me. Back to me in the studio.
I'm in this prisoners dilemma here. Are they just making this
up? Am I going to be the last one to work for the feds and then
I'm going to be the one thrown under the bus and end up being
the example publicly of look, here's the Russian spy or agent
or whatever. I don't even know what what the political point
is here. As far as I'm concerned after all of this happened,
like nothing really came of it. And um I just didn't know what
to believe. I just believed that I was in a lot of trouble. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Hold on. What is this? They
just got linked to the Discord. Sorry, this is going to be a
tangent. Listen to Breaking audio leaked from Dave. That guy
got arrested, the guy who heckled Dave Portnoy.
Um the the best I've seen from people is they tell me, well,
he threw coins at Dave, too. But it's like, did he throw the
coins at Dave's like face or like or did he throw them at his
feet as like a clearly anti-Semitic gesture? Trust me, he doesn't
want Dave catching those coins. That's not the point. The point
is supposed to be the coins hitting the ground and Dave like
leaning over to the coin. That's the joke. That's the anti-Semitic
trope he's playing on, right?
That's what's going on there. So, I get it. It's I don't know
how they're I don't know how they're charging this. It's in Mississippi.
I would have thought, if there's anywhere hate speech and hate
crime laws are lax, it's got to be Mississippi.
But apparently not. Anyway, back to Lauren Southern. >> And
you know, when you're like that deep in fear and paranoia in
that place
you just you stop knowing what's real. Every message you get,
every is silence, all of it kind of feels like it could be a
threat or a setup or something. I
my mind was just like this constant
Chaos. And at some point, everything outside me, if as long as
I was focusing on that, I was going to lose my mind. I was going
to truly lose it and not be able to function. And so I I just
went the only place that was left to go, and that was
I did the only thing I could do. It's like I I prayed. When I
tell you I prayed, I prayed. Like, God, I know we haven't talked
in a while, but
but I need some help here. I do not know what to do. And I wrote.
Like I I did
intangible reality as well that
could help me at least pro- He was just IRL donating kicks. So
true, Can the Jellyman. So true. That's what it was, okay? That
guy was throwing kicks,
individual pennies, at his favorite content creator. Like you
guys should, guys. By the way, you can buy kicks on the Kick
platform. They're like bits on Twitch. And when you donate, it's
one penny per kick. All right, there's a couple individual kicks
coming up now. I feel like I could write a script that would
like, if I get like 50 individual kicks within like a minute,
it just like does a little penny throwing animation on the screen.
People like a hand just throws pennies at me. I think I can make
it work. All right? That would actually be a great idea to trigger
special things, okay? I think it's not that hard.
We'll see. I'll I'll think about it, okay? Somebody remind me
about the idea. I'll think about it. Let's continue.
intangible reality as well that
could help me at least process what was going on. I I wrote on
paper. And I hadn't really sat down and wrote
not for work, not for a video, just for myself and to process
things going on in years. I didn't really sat and being still
in years, to be honest. But things were just such an absolute
mess on every level. It was the only thing I could do. And I
knew Wait, what?
self and to process things going on in years. I didn't really
sat and
going on. I I wrote on paper. And I hadn't really sat down and
wrote
not for work, not for a video, just for myself and to process
Okay, okay, okay. She gave the right caveat. I thought she was
saying she hadn't written stuff down or she hadn't like processed
her thoughts on paper in like years. And I was like, but you
were making videos. You're making like two videos a week.
things going on. She sounds mental. Well, Anemone, I think she's
basically said directly that she had like a psychotic break.
Right? Has she not I feel like she's very directly said, I had
a psychotic break, like a total break from reality. And she's
she's like talking through that right now. It's not like she's
trying to hide what she's talking about, right? on in years.
I didn't really sat and being still in years, to be honest. But
things were just such an absolute mess on every level. It was
the only thing I could do. And I knew it wasn't going to fix
my life or anything. But at least while I was in the midst of
a literal psyop, I could take stock of what was still mine, my
own thoughts, my own memories, my reality.
And I figured I'd go to the cafe every day and just start from
the very beginning. Piece together what had actually happened
over the last decade of my life. How does one end up in a position
where the federal government are trying to turn you into an asset?
Let Let's start from square one and work our way back. Untangle
this web. And not just like my personal decisions, but what do
these people want to know from me? What information do I have
that I'm not thinking about on a day-to-day basis that they're
trying to extract from me? My life in the political world in
general. How did I get involved in all of this? Where Where had
I been complicit in some shady or dodgy stuff going on behind
the scenes? Where had I been manipulated? What parts of my past
had I mentally rewritten to make my job and my daily life easier,
which is something we all do, by the way. There's a ton of different
words for it. Memory reconsolidation,
you know, just the idea of reconstructing things mentally for
a self-serving bias. We all naturally try to build a coherent
story about who we are. I think this is pretty true. So I pants
freedom a lot of the time. Yeah, like if if it's always happening
to somebody and it's never them doing anything bad, it it could
be a little unreliable after a while, yeah. Yeah. to make our
lives smooth and livable. Although I will say, pretty much
totally understands how they've been wronged in a situation.
So like, to some extent, everyone is like that. I would just
say the people who are consistently doing it all the time in
public and can't ever admit what they've done wrong, that's probably
not healthy.
Right? And I'm sure if you say to Lauren like, hey, you've also
done some wrong things, she would like say yes.
So, while this is a good heuristic, I I think I think pretty
much everybody's like that to some extent, too. That they they
just see how they've been wronged. It's very difficult to see
how you've wronged other people without, you know, a certain
mentality. In theory, it's supposed to do that anyways. It doesn't
always do that. I think it often does the opposite. It's not
exactly lying, but it's just unconsciously editing past events
in gentler ways. Storytelling to sustain psychological stability.
And for most people, it's just not convenient to go and deconstruct
their entire narrative identity because sometimes it means you
need to start from scratch. The operating system you've had for
30 years needs to be wiped out and you got to rebuild your sense
of reality. That's why they say people usually don't change after
30. They don't want to have to rebuild. But in a lot of cases,
it can be a good thing, especially when your mental model is
taking you to the places it has taken me. When you're in the
position I'm in I was in. Uh I really did need to remember who
I was before my brain got cooked by the political world and the
internet and governments and my own bad choices in some cases.
well, it really sucked to do. Like, damn, being honest with yourself
and your own failures, your own stupidity, your own selfish decisions,
the actual [clears throat] life story you have where Okay, I
see I see where she's going. Lauren Southern is trying to make
it in the like Brittany Simon. She's going to be like Brittany
Simon. I think that's where she's going. I think that's the goal
here. She's going to be like kind of self-help, self-forgiveness,
and she's going to talk through this stuff. And then I think
she'll be streaming like Brittany Simon is at some point in the
near maybe 6 to 12 months. I I think I Does anyone else see it?
Does anybody else see what's going on here where it's like it's
that exact like radical self-acceptance? I feel like she's going
to read The Body Keeps Score and she's going to start streaming
on it. I'm almost I'm almost positive. where you're not always
the Yeah, without the same stuff, I don't think she'll do the
same stuff, okay? Bro, every pause is a meme. What the [__]
It's the Tyzka. She just did the Tyzka. What? >> hero.
That can really suck, but it's worth it, I think, anyways. In
fact, I got to say, sitting and spending every day writing, it
was just like the only thing I could do for psychological relief.
And it was this practice of being honest with myself that was
the only way I got clear-headed enough to finally tell the feds
to shove it. Never to speak to me again. They tried blowing up
my phone and messaging me tons, but they eventually left me alone.
They're like vampires.
It was also the election. There was a bit of a dual thing going
on where I was just kind of a lot of events going on in the world
that snapped me to consciousness where I'm like, oh, you know,
I I think I'm going to be okay. I think I'm going to be okay.
And that's not to say I I think that, you know, America's going
to be okay or the world's going to be okay. It was just the political
the eye of Sauron seemed to be shifting in different directions
after the the election. But make no mistake, it's still the eye
of
Sorry, back to the feds. I say they're like vampires. I say,
you know, they're blowing up my phone. I'm constantly saying
no to them after they've been stalking me for a Did she Well,
she did talk to a lawyer. The lawyer said, don't talk to them.
But to me, like you say, so the feds apparently told her they
couldn't give her like immunity or really help. And the agent
really did do that. But I I think in my mind, the agent did that
because he's not thinking about like, how do I help Lauren Southern
or like discharging his official duties in any way. I feel like
there's some small chance that that agent knew the case was done
and he's just trying to get his what? Like
I think that's entirely possible right threatening me.
Like, we'll never get be able to sign a an immunity agreement
with you, not because we can't, but because I know that you're
like cleared already and I'm just maintaining contact and calling
you all the time from everywhere and totally obsessed. I'm telling
you, that is the thing that makes the most sense to me right
now. And I'm not saying that everyone who works in government,
that everyone who works as like a federal agent in the Western
world or non-Western world is a bad person. I'm not saying that
they're they sometimes aren't doing good work. I think there
are police that are genuinely trying to stop crime. I think there
are government officials that are genuinely trying to make the
world a better place. And I'm sure there are CSIS agents that
are genuinely concerned about the safety, both psychologically
and physically, of Canadians in a crazy world where all these
ops are going on. And you know
If they had not come in, obviously vaguely threatening me in
every conversation, refusing to give me any clear idea of why
they were there, what they allegedly had on me, what was going
on, I might have been happy to help I love the West. I am grateful
that I was born here, even
I don't want us to lose in an information war. What the [__]
you mean even Canada, you dumb [__]
Have a little pride. Holy I don't want foreign nations controlling
the media space covertly, which they definitely are trying to
do so, but it's definitely not just a Russia thing. If anything,
the Tenet stuff was like
a distraction from the massive control that is happening from
many other countries, nations, even corporations,
huge part. But even, you know, even before this Tenet stuff went
down and I had the feds doing this like weird psychological They
were They were lying to me, too. Like a bunch of the stuff they
said to me were just straight-up lies to psychologically torment
me. I can't work with people like that. I can't help you if you
treat me like an enemy when you need me to give you information.
Like even Once again, even before the Tenet stuff, I felt like
my own government treated me like an enemy. So, I just had no
faith that they had any real interest in actually listening to
me beyond what little pieces they wanted to take for a partisan
political
I I didn't feel there was any true national security agenda going
on here, and I ended up being correct in that. Because I was
dragged out to Ottawa later I at the end of November to testify
before the House of Commons. I initially said no when they invited
me, and then they compelled me under threat of arrest to come
to or threat of violating the law if I don't come talk to them.
I'm getting forced to Threat of violating the law?
Isn't that called like a like a
I think the government can literally subpoena you. I think that's
what part of their power.
Is there a country where that doesn't happen? Hey, we think you
have like information relevant to our legislative body bodies.
Here's a Here's a subpoena. Isn't that what Steve Bannon went
to jail for? Wasn't Steve Bannon Didn't he go to jail over this?
Cuz he dodged a penis from Congress? to go live stream debate
with the government when I just want to lay low and be left alone.
I go out there,
and they don't even They don't even ask me any real questions
about what's going on behind the scenes in covert control in
in the media. All of these are questions that are highly politicized.
I'm being asked like, "Why are you a bigot, Lauren? What about
this video you made 8 years ago that has nothing to do with Tenet
Media or covert control or
They have expert witnesses in this panel that are completely
lying about all the numbers of Tenet Media, saying that it was
hosting the number one podcast in the world, that it was getting
millions of views, that it's essentially the nerve center where
the Kremlin decides Western elections. This is just not what
was Oh, man. I feel like she might Is she overplaying this? We
watched that hearing.
I remember being annoyed that the hearing the people in the hearing,
some of them were like totally virtue signaling, but it's like
any congressional body. Yeah, that's going to happen. People
are going to try to like cut clips essentially. It's going to
be something that's in the news. People are going to try to do
[__] like that. That's understandable. There'll be
some people who are like asking relevant questions. I don't think
it was nearly as bad as what she's suggesting. It was like kind
of annoying, but it's like not nearly as bad as what she's suggesting
here. happening. This was a struggling media startup that struggled
to get like a thousand views on a video. In fact, the view counts
were inflated right before the indictment dropped by massive
amounts, by the way. A little odd, very odd. And and then, you
know, they have a politician there, Jennifer O'Connell on this
panel, who has actively voted and said boohoo to people asking,
"Why did you vote against
um Chinese influence within your party, people being bought and
paid for for like Chinese ops?" And they want to ask me, a regular
"What are you doing about foreign Because you were caught literally
doing
You were literally caught doing it. You were literally caught
as a part of a Russian op, you stupid
Why is she acting like this didn't happen? influence campaigns,
Lauren? I'm sorry, I'm not in power. You guys are. And in fact,
one of the people questioning me on this panel has actively voted
against investigating influence campaigns. This is absurd, ridiculous.
It was a It was like this weird like kangaroo Okay. Here you
are, Lauren. You've You've said you are aware of criminal enterprises
that run influencers that pay other influencers to take certain
sides on certain issues. I want to know about that. I want some
concrete
names. I just want names. Throw names out there. I don't even
need you to be I don't even need you to be like you don't have
to prosecute a case. Don't even give me evidence, but throw names
out. Right? If you're going to say you're schizo posting, stop
Stop talking about all the [__] that's happening
in a way where
in a way where you can just like kind of throw out innuendo and
without ever defending it. Throw out names so that you're held
accountable if they're caught in the future, right? Or if or
you're lauded if they're caught in the
What's holding you back from throwing out the names? kangaroo
trial humiliation thing. I'm getting called an anti-Semite out
of nowhere. Doesn't even make sense. And I ask him like, "Okay,
why why are you calling me that?" Well, you inter- I remember
this is because she interviewed Dugin.
That That I remember calling that one out, okay?
I remember If you guys are curious about my stance, if that's
ever changed, all right? People calling out anti-Semitism where
it clearly doesn't exist because for no reason, that's always
been a trigger for me. Literally always.
Didn't you interview one of the biggest anti-Semites in the world?
You know that makes you an anti-Semite, right? interviewed Alexander
Dugin. Okay, well, so did TVO's Steve Paikin. What do you What
do you mean? Oh, well, I didn't watch either interview, but I
know yours was
It was the most ridiculous experience I've ever had in my life.
Jennifer O'Connell ended up not taking her chance to interview
me at all because I called her out, and she's like, "Oh, I I
can't say anything here." They let me go early because I'm cleaning
up, and I don't even want it. Like it doesn't even feel good
at this point. I'm just like, "This is depressing." Canadians
have probably spent uh definitely hundreds of thousands, if not
over a million dollars, on this whole disinformation campaigns
in Canada uh committee that's been put together by the parliament.
Nothing came of it. I mentioned to them that there was a Chinese
spy that was trying to get me to go out to the Donbas
to do uh you know, videos there that I said no to. And they didn't
ask me any more questions about it. They didn't They didn't Not
even curious. They're just like, "Okay, sorry, my talking points
say to call you uh names, Lauren, and then say Russia are the
reason we Those are politicians.
I bet you if you're like if you
Wouldn't Canadian intelligence have been really excited to hear
that? Did you mention that to Canadian intelligence? Have they
asked you about that since? I feel like I would want them to
go and look into that if you could give
That would be interesting to me. We have bad housing problems
here in Canada. Uh no, they didn't seem actually curious about
what was going on behind the scenes in media manipulation whatsoever,
and you can go and watch all of these committees and figure that
out for yourself. It was tragic. Here are some of the Here are
some of the clips. I want to go back to your trip that you took
to Russia in 2018. Who paid for that trip? I paid for it. You
mentioned that you did um several interviews there. Were you
paid for those interviews? I was not paid to do any of those
interviews. So, you I I mean, it's come up who you interviewed
while you were there. This is This was annoying. I called it
out as annoying at the time. Alexander Dugin, who not only has
been referred to as Vladimir Putin's brain. Dugin said Russia
should quote
He's previously been involved with Pamyat, which has been described
as the most anti-significant anti-Semitic organization since
perestroika.
He's expressed his admiration for the SS, adopting the alter
ego
named Hans Sievers, name I'll be honest,
I want this person's bank account investigated.
Please look at their bank account, see if there's any uh curious
payments going into it, okay? >> after the war criminal
who was general secretary of a research institute. Not that Not
that it's not criticizable to like give Dugin a puff piece, okay?
You could criticize on that front, but I think like going super
deep into the anti-Semitic elements of what Dugin says is kind
of goofy. When I I feel like just the anti-Western rhetoric is
obviously all I would care about.
But it's fine. I'm Himmler Himmler established. I'm just curious.
I know you've mentioned Steve Paikin a number of times, and I
had limited time to look here, slightly different than than the
interview that that you did. I'll just be honest. I'm Why would
you want to platform someone like that? The exact same reasons
reason Steve Paikin did, and TVO did. Because he is an interesting
geopolitical figure, and I was more right than I bargained for
initially at how interesting he would >> Do Do you agree
with his views on on No. I don't think we should Ukrainians.
On the contrary, I think we should be trying to
not anybody. Not Not a big fan of people. Ukraine Hey, dude.
This is the laziest Anytime somebody answers this way, okay?
Hey, is this
Hey, when when
I'm just thinking of like a murder. Do you Do you disavow O.J.
Simpson for killing his wife? Let's say hypothetically O.J.'s
found guilty. Do you disavow O.J. Simpson for killing his wife?
Uh I think all killing is bad. It's like that's not the question
you were asked. That's literally not the question you were asked.
You're asked about a specific instance. This actually happened
with Ben
No, not Ben Shapiro. It was Matt Walsh and Sneako. Matt Walsh
tried to come back at Sneako and say something along the lines
of like, "Oh, actually, I just think all foreign funding in politics
is bad, and I don't think that should happen." When When Sneako
So, I don't even know what we debate. What are we going to debate
about? Oh, I'm just going to say that Israel shouldn't get special
treatment. It's like, "No, the question is does Israel get special
treatment now, you
Stop pretending that stating a preference is is actually an answer
to being asked about a a specific instance of Oh, that question
happening. It's It's not the same thing. It's the clearly not
the same thing. Canadian or otherwise. And do do you prescribe
to his anti-Semitic views? No. No, once again, Oh, sorry, she
did. I was really just triggered about the Matt Walsh thing,
to be honest with you. That's really mostly what I wanted to
rant about was the Matt Walsh thing cuz it [__] annoys
me. Um you're interviewing me right now. Do you agree with all
of my opinions? No, I actually find some of them quite offensive.
I'm I'm just curious what a Canadian language is. Is that Ojibway
and Cree? Typically, in Canada, our national languages are English
and I I kind of figured this was common knowledge in here, but
Okay. Um then This person was the worst questioner. Yeah, we
I remember mocking the [__] out of this person. This
person was [__] You you
you keep referring to Steve Paikin and the fact that he did an
interview with someone. Um
you went to Russia, if I'm not mistaken, you were barred from
going to the UK. Is that correct? Uh yes, I was barred from going
to the UK. And why was that? That was because I tried to set
up a pride parade in Luton and the Islamic population there typically
are not a big fan of that and I was told that it was stirring
up hatred. And so you went to Russia to stir up hatred against
I'm so sorry. What What are you referring to? >> Look who
you Look who you you you deliberately made a trip to Russia to
interview someone who is is one of the most anti-Semitic people
Again, this is I want this person's bank account looked
I want it looked at, okay?
I just around?
Is Like is it just to be controversial? Is that You find that
funny? >> part I do find it funny that you are accusing
me of taking a trip to Russia to stir up hatred around when I
don't If I felt like Lauren had done anything to go Is this the
Senate? No, this is the Canadian uh legislative investigative
body. Like there there's
legislators in here. Like actual members of parliament are in
this this body. I don't know exactly what this Oh, Standing Committee
on Public Safety and National Security. There you go. So the
Standing Committee that's made up of Canadian politicians. This
is in Canada this is happening.
And we This happened like a year and a half ago. And yeah, some
of the questions were embarrassing because obviously politicians
are politicians. They want their questions to be like to be useful
for other things for political goals, right? So they're not always
going to ask the best questions.
Uh Dolce Dolce Bellum and I expertise says, "How are their interview
questions so bad? Have you literally ever watched a congressional
hearing?"
I don't know if you know this, Dolce Bellum, but politicians
don't really care about the truth. They care about their political
narratives, their political goals. That's what they're always
operating on, right? Yes. Yes, this is just like a congressional
It's They're They're going to ask the worst questions. A lot
of them are going to ask horrible questions. Some of them will
ask relevant questions, but
it's just the way it is. came up once during my interview with
Alexander Dugin. I don't know where you're getting that from.
And once again, Steve Paikin conducted an interview with him.
I guess you would have to make the same anti-Semitic accusation
against TVO. Ms. Southern, his views are well-known and you you
deliberately went there. So you're you're basically trying to
create chaos. Funny thing is, that's what they say Russia does
with all the things that they do is try to create chaos in society.
So I It sounds like your goal is to try and and uh create chaos
and uh I don't get the sense that you have a lot of um respect
for Western liberal democracy as it is. So anyway, that's my
time, Chair. Wow. And if so, what responsibility do you believe
that individuals like yourself and in your platform prevent in
you know, aid in in
uh the spread of foreign influence? I think that it is rich that
I'm sat here and being asked what I have to do to stop foreign
influence and foreign interference as a Canadian citizen while
we sit here with MPs like Jennifer O'Connell who said I Uh it
feels so weird to me, like so annoying that Lauren's not really
taking accountability for her part in an in a foreign influence
campaign at all. She's not taking accountability whatsoever and
she's using the one Congress who asked asked totally questions
as like her entire hit piece against like any questions into
her involvement with
It's like
I It's just goofy, okay? It To me, I'm I'm I get super annoyed.
It's like you actually did something bad. You should accept that
you did something bad. You should take responsibility for it.
And she's like, "Nah, I'm just going to Here's like the one person
who tried to insist I was an anti-Semite cuz I interviewed Dugin."
said boohoo to conservatives who wanted actual elected politicians
working with foreign governments to be exposed. So I take it
you don't take responsibility. So sorry, I take it you don't
take responsibility. I'm sorry, it's not your turn, Ms. O'Connell.
You can continue. How do you reconcile your business model which
prioritizes user engagement and and raking in massive profits
from clicks with the necessity to protect users from Yes, Dung
Devil. Lauren was misled about where the money from Tennet was
coming
Um she was misled. I don't believe there's like evidence that
she was influenced significantly on her topics. Right? I don't
think there is. But she was a part of it. She was close to these
She does say that she has like evidence or some understanding
that a lot of people have taken money from foreign influence
campaigns. Right? That governments are buying their opinion.
She says she has evidence of that. She says she's seen it happen.
So I I feel like the government wanted to talk to her, like the
Canadian intelligence agencies wanted to talk to her. Makes a
ton of sense wanting her to be an asset who they can ask questions
But now she's pretending the whole thing's like a total joke,
like it's total witch hunt. I don't think it's a total witch
hunt. I think your cooperation would be helpful and would help,
I guess, possibly point people in the right direction of as to
who they should be investigating and why. harmful disinformation
that can lead to real-world consequences like hate speech violence.
How is anyone in this committee supposed to stop disinformation
abroad if they can't stop it within this committee? Why wasn't
Ben Scott Why wasn't he challenged when Uh if she's misled about
the money is uh where the money is coming from, what is there
to for her to take accountability for? It seems you want her
to accept some sort of moral fault. Uh no, I don't want her to
take to accept moral fault for these allegations. What I want
her to do is know that if I were, you know, I were the banker
for some
uh movement who lynched a bunch of people to bunch of people.
I wouldn't feel bad for those killings, but I would feel bad
if I didn't do everything in my power to help the like law enforcement
intelligence agencies track down the people who had done those
crimes. I did help them. I did aid them
But then for me to dodge helping in any way to solve those crimes,
to further those investigations, and then go, "This is total
witch hunt. This is total garbage." It's like, "No." And then
she's simultaneously claiming, "Like I have knowledge that these
things happened, but nobody wants to talk to me about it."
Uh a Chinese spy tried to pay me to go to Russia in in the before
the war broke out to go to the Donbas. Okay, did you tell CSIS
about this or did you just say it once in this congressional
in this hearing right here?
Okay. Yeah, that is my that is my problem with Lauren Southern
right now is that she's she's acting like this didn't matter,
like this wasn't a big deal. No, it was a big deal. It was obviously
a big deal. Pretending nothing happened here, pretending that
like there's no reason to talk to these people, there's no reason
to cooperate, there's no reason to do anything. She's mistrusted
the government all her life. Yeah, she has. And like I'm fine
with that, but you just have to pick one side of the coin. Either
either these influence campaigns are happening, you have information,
you have understanding of it, and you should help, or you don't
want to help and you don't have any solid information. Like you
did help this influence campaign gain some measure of respectability
and trust within the West. You should feel some debt to pay that
back. In my opinion, right? In my opinion. Now obviously the
rest of the people here are total pieces of [__]
too. Obviously Tim Pool uh Tim Pool, Benny Johnson, and Dave
Rubin should have absolutely known that they were being used.
Right? They They went really far out of their way. Lauren took
less money. She didn't have like a totally suspicious amount
of money to do her job, right? It's like she's probably getting
overpaid, but she wasn't being overpaid anywhere near at the
rate of those other people. So that's understandable, too, that
she she feels like she had way less reason to suspect it was
a foreign influence campaign. When he cited false numbers about
Tennet's views, why wasn't he challenged when it was said that
Tennet created the top podcast in the world, that they were getting
billions of impressions? No. No, she stated she said this at
this hearing full of hell and they didn't ask her questions at
this hearing. These are politicians. They're not intelligence
If we cannot stop disinformation within this committee, I'm sorry,
but no one here is stopping disinformation coming from a broad
or foreign interference. What Okay. So right now you're telling
us right now that you're not going to take any any different
steps to ensure that the people that are paying you are legitimate
and don't have a criminal record. The steps I'm taking is I'm
not going to work in media again because I am tired of the subterranean
fed level nonsense going on and I would like to just go on with
my normal life as a
not being She says but shortly before publishing a book. All
right. Shortly before shilling that book via her YouTube channel
and her Twitter. All right. Like this is
Uh I understand changing your mind, man, but this seems kind
of bull to me. Uh thank you, Mr. Johnson. But anyways, like it
wasn't even, you know, I definitely got a kick out of it
I was trying to take a break from media and not be online anyway
cuz I that was warping my mind, too. Just all the likes, the
clicks, the views, the this, the that, the audience capture that
happens to everyone, and other drama that we'll talk about in
a moment here, but >> Drama? You know, I just after I left
So did you lie to Did you lie to that committee? Here she is
making another video. More videos, more clicks, more social media
appearances.
Um I remember being in the cab on the way back from
from the whole shebang in Ottawa and I just like sobbed. I was
like, "Is it over? Is this done? Are they going to leave me alone
now?" The entire experience, quite frankly, nearly mentally broke
me. But I am I'm really glad it happened. Genuinely. I'm not
even a cope. I am incredibly grateful that all of this happened
because I definitely wouldn't have sat and spent all that time
writing. I definitely wouldn't have spent the many months afterwards
not being on social
really digging deep and reckoning with myself, trying to understand
what what had happened, how I had gotten here. And uh I ended
up writing down a good chunk of my life story throughout this
process. I And I told myself, you know, uh maybe, you know, some
of this is interesting. Maybe I'll show people this, but I'm
definitely not going to show people the everything I'm writing.
It's too crazy. It's too personal.
Uh it's too embarrassing in some cases.
I ended up publishing that book 3 months ago, though. It's actually
called This Is Not Real Life. And it is a collection of the actual
stories behind the scenes of my time in politics in hopes that
uh by understanding, I guess, what my journey looked like and
how I got caught up in all this madness, that it can perhaps
help people assess the entire political world better, or at least
realize that they shouldn't believe most of what they see online.
This may be your first time hearing of the book, particularly
because I turned down almost every single interview request about
it, as one of the main theories of my book is that everything
is fake now. Not not like everything, but the vast majority of
it. Journalists simply don't make money anymore from telling
the truth. Left or right, they get paid to make clickbait. They
get paid to make things that people want to read, true or not.
And they definitely don't get >> thing was an ad. I mean,
it's starting to seem that way. I'm kind of I'm kind of checking
out on this, to be honest.
Like, at this point, like getting like like baited this amount,
I'm just like, oh, I'll probably just wait until somebody else
reviews this stuff the next time. Do you know what I mean? Like,
I I was told, oh, you know, influencers get paid by cults, governments,
and corporations, or sometimes all three. It's like, okay, I've
So, let's see some evidence of that. And I've seen nothing. This
entire time there has been nothing.
paid to truly understand or communicate things. The best I've
seen The best part about this was Lauren Southern not understanding
that this intelligence agent, this uh CSIS agent, was trying
to [__] her. That's That's like the funniest part.
>> there's like a very small group that still exists that
are doing that. And I can say this is even true of my time at
Tenet, where I had full control of everything. I had the full
ability, Lauren, you can make whatever videos you want. Total
freedom of speech, but my con- my contract just had me doing
so much content that none of it could be truly deep or meaningful.
You know, and this was a compromise I made. I was like, okay,
you know, I have free speech, all the company backing me. Everyone
else in this sphere is doing like daily videos. Lauren, you got
to catch up. You got to You know, if you can't beat them, join
them. And I found myself staying up to like 5:00 a.m.
and trying to fact-check stories that still I couldn't get right
because there Why didn't she just rethink the kind of content
she was making? I Like, realistically, I spend a lot of this
stream Like, we don't we we do the work of like understanding
things on the stream. Turning that into a process is very nice
because you If you do turn that into a process where you're like
going through you have like your questions, you explain your
thought process to people, you try to explain what questions
you think should be asked, and you turn that into an entertainment
product, that can be like lucrative still. It can It can be That's
basically what this stream is a lot of times is we just go through
we we like actually spend the time going through a bunch of facts
on political stories, drama stories, all of this stuff, right?
Try to figure out what the opinion should be. I don't know why
she wouldn't have done some of that. Like, why don't you just
start Yeah, producing videos on like how you make your content,
like meta commentary, right? Like, I'm sure there'd be some interesting
things that you could do there.
Or maybe maybe her contract was really specific, I don't know.
>> was just no
I would have myself trying to make money reporting accurate and
meaningful and still get like three videos out a week. That's
just too much content. And so, it just becomes like Oh, another
video on the woke mind virus that you've heard repeated 7,000
different ways. And you know, silly me, silly me, case in point,
I recently broke my rule and I said yes to a long-form written
interview about the book. Only cuz like the person said they
read the book and they they were really, you know, they wanted
to do it justice. Then I go and I read this article and I'm learning
new lore about myself. I I discover that I was stalked by Gavin
McInnes for months, apparently.
This is simply not true. He didn't even I don't even think he
came up in the interview questions he asked me. And uh quite
frankly, out of the many stalkers that I have had in my life,
I wish it were Gavin because instead he'd be funny, at least,
you know? And then just so many little details that were just
wrong. And I I asked him like, okay, wait, what How did you get
this Where did you get this from? She responds in email and she's
like, oh, well, I referenced another article I found. Another
fake clickbait,
you know, nonsense reporting trying to exaggerate or misrepresent
things to get attention. And it just becomes this massive game
of Chinese telephone, even when people are spending a long time
on articles. Like, I think this person spent like a month writing
it or something. And then, you know, like, it's it's not partisan.
I saw Liz Wheeler, I didn't talk to her about my book, but she
read a headline about my book from someone else and decided to
do a story on it and accidentally spent her whole video agreeing
with everything I'd written in the book, but delivering her video,
entitling it as an aggressive debunking of me because she was
under the impression my book said the opposite of what she thought
it said.
Because she didn't read it. And I have nothing [clears throat]
Wait. What? She agreed with you? She spent the entire video agreeing
with
But she framed it as a disagreement cuz she didn't read anything.
>> against Liz. She seems like a nice lady. >> What
What was she agreeing with? It's not even her fault. She's just
following what is industry standard right now, and that is clickbait
purgatory. She didn't read the source material because nobody
does any anymore. Reading source material means A, putting in
effort, and B, potentially being exposed to information that
doesn't fit nicely into your clickbait echo chamber. And neither
of those things are socially or financially
Or fun. That's fun. That's just not true.
That's just not true, Lauren.
Unfortunately, I know like many people who do streams that are
profitable, that make money, that literally just run this exact
thing where they're going to read through the source material.
I've read basically uh I I did read her article from today, but
I watched your full video. I read all of the articles you published
around the Andrew Tate stuff.
And she's just lying. I'm I'm like literally sitting here as
a counterexample. Like, there are people who can do this. Will
I ever go like massively viral? Not unless I get funnier, which
is obviously not going to happen, so we're [__] But,
you know, maybe maybe we get lucky, okay? Or listen, Israel,
I'm not making enough money, okay? I'm ready to switch sides.
I'm ready to switch sides, just send the check, okay? Put the
check in the mail, I'll switch sides immediately. Uh this was
a very consistent review I got of my book from those who actually
read it was that while they thought it was a very good read,
it wasn't necessarily a comfortable one. Which, fair enough,
it wasn't exactly a comfortable write either, but it is honest.
And, you know, The New York Times also did a piece on the on
a few of the chapters in the book about my marriage. They, of
course, cherry-picked bits that they felt could be spun for their
ideological purposes.
Uh though I did And they ignored like the rest of the book. I
always I was like, why doesn't anyone care about this federal
agent stuff? This is like crazy work, and no one did any journalistic
stories. They were just like, oh, what can we comment about the
trad life? What What can we, you know, whether it be a left or
right attack, what can we say?
I did appreciate, however, that The New York Times did begrudgingly
admit it's uh it's hard to see a professional motive in a book
that's likely to annoy every political faction. Even saying that
it's uh it made the book more credible in some cases. And yeah,
I appreciate that. >> I I don't expect her to like literally
watch this stuff, Real Doctor [snorts] Cube, but she's just saying
it doesn't exist, and it's like, no, it does exist, like all
over the place, actually. And I think they were right. Uh I didn't
get a big fancy book deal. I definitely I could make more money
off of like four or five YouTube ad reads than I would off this
book because there's no ideological app dance for publishers
to sell or the masses to consume in it. It's just like the truth
as
plain and simple as sh- annoying as it is, worldview-breaking
as it is sometimes. Like,
I understand some of what she's saying. She's taking it a little
too far. It's like, people do clickbait and then do like very
truthful or very like real reactions and content, right? That
are like 100% just factual and then they're readings of the facts.
You can not like the readings of the facts, you can think it's
like spin and
That's fine. But I don't I don't think it's like fake.
Like, you can't just look at titles and go, oh, this is fake
cuz the title doesn't capture the content perfectly. It's like,
yeah, people do clickbait with titles. But you
you want to look like the look at the actual content, too. times
and harsh as it is sometimes. And, you know, everyone did hate
it. Left and right took their turns throwing me under the bus.
The leftist approach was generally wow, you do this book talking
about the problems within, you know, dissident media sphere,
and you don't disavow every belief you've ever had in your entire
life. You alt-right
Apparently, I'm not allowed to grow, mature in my beliefs, and
honestly look at my past unless I want open borders
politics and to become or something, I guess. I I don't
People get way too Like, I'm probably susceptible to this, too.
They get way too sensitive to like criticisms they're getting,
and they think the criticisms are like most of the the [__]
that's being said. Right? Like, that is possible that the criticisms
are most of what's being said. It's possible.
But sometimes I think people like they they just shine so bright
in people's minds that they think there's like a lot of worse
things going on than there are. Like, I I don't ridiculous. Meanwhile,
a good chunk of my old right-wing peers were busy seething that
I'd said the quiet part out loud, that it's all fake, and power
corrupts every ideology, including their sphere. They also like
taking money to write nonsense, post not What was the maturing
aside from I'm right now? Well, technically, she was right before,
but
I think the the changes were, oh, I don't really think anybody's
sincere anymore, right? I think I'm very jaded on all of this.
Like, I do think the right wing is bad. Here's like all the bad
experiences I had in the right wing. And I don't think the left
wing wing is better, so I'm going to be, you know, politically
homeless. I'm not going to do content anymore. Was Was what was
being said. nonsense. You know, much like the devil can cite
scripture, the right wing can make fake news, too. But you know
who didn't hate it? You know who didn't hate it? Bless you, people.
Those who actually read it. I know you're a few, but meaningful
and thoughtful, and I appreciate it. And uh you know what? All
the influencers who called me behind the scenes and said, for
what it's worth, Lauren, we know everything in your book is true.
We'd lose our jobs, our funding, important contacts, etc. if
we said so. I got a lot of those calls, and I, you know,
I See, this is to me, if you're willing to talk about any of
that, if it was all
and you had real examples,
why are you refusing to say it? I'm sitting here for the examples
of the things that would make people lose their money, make people
lose their sh
What is it? Other than Andrew Tate's a ra I don't know if you
noticed, Lauren. Tons of people are willing to say Andrew Tate's
a ra
Yeah, that's like not even That might be the median opinion.
In the world, Andrew Tate is a ra
I'm not even mad. I'm not Maybe a little. I did, you know, see
the little and I'm like, "Ugh." It sucks when people can say
things privately, but can't publicly, but I also get it because
I've been there, too. I've been in their shoes.
One thing, you know, I worried about when I published Honestly,
as well, those people piss me off. I'm not going to say they
piss me off as much as Andrew Tate does, okay? Cuz Andrew Tate's
like obviously the ra here. But in my head, I'm like, "Bro, I
Like these people who are like too cowardly to just say their
opinion on this like out in the open?"
Those people, too. Triple those people.
Oh, I'm actually going to let you know that I support you, but
I'll never say it publicly.
in a video game cuz we're on Twitch. this book cuz it kind of
feels like it's this indictment of all influencers and all influencer
culture, and it's not. I actually love these people. I don't
hate
or people in the political media space, even the ones that have
like taken money to do say horrible things about me or this and
that. I I don't even hate them. I hate the place they're stuck
in. I hate the system. Here's the paradox. Dissident media was
meant So, this is like I believe she says that Milo got paid
to write an article on her. I could believe that a little bit.
But I don't think he's getting paid life-changing money, and
I don't think many people think Milo's
Like that is a That's like him getting paid a little bit of money
to write a hit piece on you is like so low-level compared to
all the other stuff he gets done or said. meant to challenge
power. Yet, the internet turned it into this trap because once
you're labeled canceled, you can't go back. One Google search
and you're done. A lot of these people can never get a normal
job again, which ironically made dissident media one of the easiest
spaces for governments, corporations, and bad actors to capture.
And quite frankly, I think people that are, you know, got to
take some responsibility here are those who tried to gerrymander
who could be involved in public discourse a decade ago, who tried
to create this eternal record of bigoted bad people online and
dub them unemployable in any sphere except making controversial
content. Most of whom were just young nerds who got caught up
in exploring politics in like 2015 and made a few edgy jokes.
When the internet makes you unemployable and your own government
makes you untouchable, what choice are people left with if they
want to eat but to take money from dodgy sources, dodgy people?
And I'm not saying it's right. It's not. Uh I basically make
all of my money or like a significant portion of my money based
on one billionaire's
gambling empire, okay? There it is. There it is. If this gambling
empire was not paying me at all, I do not know if I would be
doing content. I'm telling you the truth, okay? I'm being fully
honest out there with you guys, okay? I don't know if I'd be
doing content. If we're If we're not on YouTube, and Kick is
the only place that can sustain this sh okay? If I stream If
If Kick ever disappears or KCIP ever disappears,
uh and I can't get a YouTube thing figured out, probably a lot
fewer streams, okay?
But I'm telling you where my money comes from. And thank God
Thank God for Eddie, okay? Cuz you don't have to be concerned
about me couching my opinions. Eddie will just pay me to say
whatever I want.
Eddie doesn't tell me. All I have to do Actually, I don't even
have to say that gambling's cool. I I've talked about how [__]
gambling is all the time.
But it's just that one guy, that one that one Aussie billionaire
who's got a gambling empire who sustains my entire paycheck for
me, okay? Or like a huge portion of it. not right. It's just
reality. When you effectively create a social credit system based
on people's edgy politics they had in college, you might as well
create a recruitment center for threats to national security.
And uh you know, I'm not This might sound like it's all about
the tennis stuff. It's not. Like there is money being thrown
in from all over the place towards influencers, and people are
just like, "Oh, I'm not going to look that hard into it because
I got to eat, you know?" That's kind of And the massive demonetization
of political content, I I get it. I'm not saying it's right,
but this is like the natural result of the pressures that have
been put on this space. And we're about to repeat the cycle the
other way around, by the way. Obviously, politics has just been
a nonstop chain of acting out against your own morality because
the other guy broke the rules first, going all the way back to
when the first caveman hit another caveman. >> This is
all This is all true. Again, it's like some things are just naturally
true. Yes. Yes. Yes.
We're back up. We're up in the cliches per second again, cliches
per minute. They're going back up. Give me 1 second. rock. I
I love like the everyone's saying, you know, it's it's our turn.
It's our turn to mass cancel and kind of destroy the other side.
It's Everyone has infinite motivation to sell out, to not tell
the truth, to have no mercy or understanding for anyone else,
to not like stick to their moral principles. Just everyone And
they all have like very stories that you can sympathize with
for the reasons for doing so. And to put the cherry on top, everything
is utterly godless. The performative Christianity, even more
so than anything else, which means even more bad actors taking
control of the whole political sphere. And it doesn't cost much,
either. It doesn't take much money to buy an influencer, even
when they're not canceled. And all of it is made to look authentic
to the average person consuming political content. That's the
purpose. And it's not just foreign governments or domestic, but
criminals doing this as well, buying your psyche by purchasing
the opinion of media figures and buying your feeds. And they're
I can't I can't defend this opinion too well, okay? I'm not like
equipped to defend this opinion, but it is like my opinion
basically being a Christian influencer is like an oxymoron. Like
you It's basically paradoxical. Like if you were truly like a
Christian, almost certainly the way you have to build yourself
as an influencer makes no sense. Like there's there's basically
nobody who comes out and is like, "I'm I'm just like I'm just
trying to spread the word of God." No.
That's That's how I feel about it,
I think basically all of them are like that. I
I don't know, man. I I'm sure there's like some people who are
like, "But it it can't be like the center of your content, and
you can't be like this contentious person." But we'll see. therefore
making themselves valuable in the eyes of politicians, therefore
making themselves have more sway behind the scenes to influence
their cases, their travel. And because this is All of this stuff
if the way that the system works, whether you're banned from
countries or not, my ban
to America, I wasn't allowed to go for 2 years, was lifted the
second I had a a friend in the administration that I could call
up to get it lifted. These things aren't based as much on the
law or seeming rules that you would think they are. They're based
on whose friends are in power and whose aren't, right? So, there
is a lot of benefit to manipulating the psyche to get yourself
power, especially if you're doing criminal things, which our
government s
the Western world just seem fully unequipped to deal with as
digital crime is on the rise, and we just live in this increasingly
low-trust society day by day, where everything is becoming a
scam, everything is becoming manipulation behind the scenes.
I discussed this in my book as well, including getting into some
of the more serious criminal underbelly of the political world.
I might as well just say it because some of you have probably
already seen this online anyway, but I do talk about the Tate
brothers and their whole very obvious criminal operation. Oh,
it's just the Tates,
It's just the Tates.
If you're brain dead enough to hear a guy tell you, "I am a pimp,
and I moved to Romania to get away with crime easier," and you
can't figure out what's going on there,
not to mention all of the other information available, just that,
I don't know what to tell you. I truly don't know what to tell
you. But either way, I published all those chapters for free
because I didn't want any weirdos accusing me of writing them
for money, though they did anyway. Hey ho. Uh those Substack
are below in the description.
I don't really want to talk about all that in this video. I already
wrote about it. You can read it there. If you followed me over
the years, uh you know I don't just say [__] Um like
maybe when I was younger and I was really going off about the
marriage like cultural stuff that I didn't know, but when it
comes to like a story that I understand and have looked into,
I tend to have a bit of a Cassandra syndrome, where I'm right
too early, then vindicated years later, like the Mass Graves
scandal stuff in Canada. And I don't expect this She's just like
Sneako. Her and Sneako are the same person, actually. She's just
like Sneako.
The Mass Graves thing was actually [__] up, but if
she talks about migration, I'm going to lose it. >> any
different. I mean, after I published my book, the Tates had their
dorky lawyer McBride do a little performative dance saying they're
going to sue me for everything I'm worth. They're going to sue
me. It's been over 3 months, and I haven't gotten so much as
a cease and desist. There's a reason for that. So much of the
stuff you see about that sphere and what's going on there, it's
performative, and you are being manipulated.
But hey, moving on from that, we'll see. [snorts] We'll see what
happens there. What I wrote over the last year, I swear, isn't
all just depressing stuff. It's not all a black pill. It's not
all about, you know, how >> It's Jesus. There is something
I'm not going to say it. the whole space is doomed, and there's
nothing we can do about it. Not to spoil the end, but I do think
it's an optimistic book, in my opinion. And there's a good mix
of humor in there, too, to offset the chaos. I get stuck in the
Arctic with There's getting arrested in Morocco, Turkey, banned
from the UK. The fun ridiculous behind-the-scenes stuff of my
trips to South Africa and Russia, the making of Farmlands, Borderless,
and other projects, my time working at Rebel Media. And uh more
details on Tenet and my slow descent into madness with my federal
agent stalking me. And yes, I do get into some of the bigger
internet dramas that I have seemingly avoided discussing over
the last few years here, like the Destiny drama. And you know
what? If you're desperate for tea, there's two whole chapters
on that in the book, okay?
Hey guys. [laughter] Notes from the editing desk.
Oh, wow. Uh I'm still never buying that book. Literally never
buying that book. Never doing that. >> Despite just saying
if you want to hear more on the subject, read the book, I somehow
then managed to go on an hour-long rant about this, which mostly
amounts to how I'm the main character of human suffering, and
nobody understands me. So, instead of subjecting you to that
embarrassing display, we're going to fast-forward through all
of that with exception to a few key out-of-context highlights
that I'll leave in. From BPD arthoes to buy leftist goth chicks,
sit this one out. I'm literally you, mentally ill from too much
time on the internet. I feel like this is going to be Please
don't let this be for like a patron or something. I swear to
god. >> it to happen. I'm not having a normal one over
here. Dude, I I'm not going to lie. I went from like being on
Lauren's side to borderline becoming misogynist because of this
video. Like I I worked on myself for a long time to kind of curb
the misogyny in so many ways and I'm about to start I'm I'm like
I'm right there. I'm like about to go the [__] off
on this [__] Like this is just This is millennial
woman drinking wine and being like snarky and it is the most
common phenotype on the entire internet. It is so so so common
and somehow it's like the the thinking that this is interesting
is so frustrating to me. Trust me, there are many women who do
this and are actually intelligent and actually make good points
and actually have something entertaining, right, to say. There
are tons of them.
I can watch their content. This is >> What did I deal with?
Videos with 20,000 views analyzing the flame war in the comment
section of my WikiFeet page cuz my toes were too bent. Okay,
that's funny. Hold on. That's funny. >> analyzing the flame
war in the comment section of my WikiFeet page cuz my toes were
too bent. Most people in reality just cannot deal with that and
I I don't blame them. Obviously someone like Destiny was uniquely
equipped to relate with me on those levels and that, you know,
you don't feel so alone in the world. That's a nice thing. I
don't expect everyone to get it. That's fine. But uh outside
the spectacle of clickbait, these internet characters and the
real moments they're living pulled as the
Did he empathize with you? I think you wanted to keep your son's
name private and he was like totally talking about that name
with this uh I guess 18 17-year-old at the time, not that he
knew 17-year-old at the the time that he knew for I think 2 months.
He just decided to send all of your private messages to this
person.
I don't know I don't know if he's really empathizing or if he's
just trying to smash, but yeah. human experiences, I I just I
think it explains the political sphere more than any of the polished
commentary or Twitter post posturing ever could. And uh you know,
if you do take the time to read the book, I think you'll realize
it's not actually about Gos at all. It's not even really about
me. It's about what all of the the strange stories I have to
tell and the manipulation and corruption I saw in the political
world means for you, for the millions of people who have been
invested in this online theater, for how we live, how we think,
and how the internet has reshaped reality itself. Certainly for
me, but for everyone else, you know, everyone's becoming increasingly
online the way I was the last 10 years. And my hope is that if
you do decide to read the book, you don't just change your opinion
about me or some headline like, "Damn." You may think I'm worse
after reading this book. So, my hope instead is really that if
you read this is not real life, you just start seeing the whole
online world a little differently even if it's Okay, I'm going
to end on Twitch though, guys. We're going to end on Twitch.
We're going to go over to Kick only. Guys, I think we're one
sub
Yeah, one sub away from another hour on the stream. So, let's
get that sub in. Well, actually, you should get a lot of subs
in so we can go for a long time tonight. I've got tons of content
to watch, okay? But yeah, I'm going to I'm going to head off
of Twitch cuz I just the the Twitch audience goes down, people
end up going over to Kick anyway and
I think we've got 11 viewers or 13 viewers over there right now.
You know, if we had a ton of viewers right now, I would I would
go harder on Twitch. >> Okay? I would. I promise I would.
Don't be cheap. >> Uh also, thank you to Slime for the
gifted sub. Appreciate it, buddy. Add that extra hour to the
stream. We're going to keep going. We have lots of content to
cover tonight, guys, so >> Get subs in. Get the subs in.
That's happy. My expense. And I get it like the the audience
for this project has been small. Like it's it's a big ask to
tell people to read a book these days. But uh the audience has
also been really thoughtful and I I've loved that I've actually
been able to read and respond to emails and reviews. Though I
will say I'm very amused by how many of you are surprised or
shocked that I can write. I'll take it as a compliment. Thank
you. Um And uh there there will of course be noise, arguments
in the comment section, bots, PR campaigns trying to spin what
I've said, and that's just unavoidable in this ecosystem, you
know? But if you really really care to understand, if you got
strong feelings about me and my
just go read the book. Don't scroll. You know, make up your own
mind. You don't even need to pay for it. This is it. I I like
I I people we live in such a world of um materialism that it
seems people's only idea of the reason someone would write a
book is to make money. Like yeah, you know, if I spend a year
working on something, almost a year, like thousands of hours
working on something, it would be nice to be compensated somewhat.
But there have been a lot of books written through history because
they were important to the collective consciousness and the political
conversations of the time. And there are reasons to write things
beyond just making money. If I wanted to make money, I'd do some
book where I'm like, you know, pouring out a bottle of red If
your opinions were important to the political collective consciousness,
I feel like you could you would do videos on them that aren't
this and I feel like you'd support them.
You know, you should read her book. I
I'm sorry. If they're if they're important, then throw them out
there, right? She said, "Oh, I could make more money off of YouTube
ad reads." Then do that and put them out as YouTube videos with
all the evidence there. Don't hide it behind the book. Don't
hide it behind the book, man. >> I'm like, "How did I turn
me into a feminist or something?" Man, I get it. Or If they're
if they're really important to have out there, why not do both?
Why not have the book and then also put it in your YouTube videos,
the actual facts instead of keeping spoilers or keeping like
relevant facts in the book? Ted Talk for that, you know.
Yeah, you don't even need to pay for it. >> Yeah, you I
know you're >> at a bunch of local libraries. I know my
local library in Vancouver has a few copies there. Um if yours
doesn't, you can call them and ask them to order a copy. So,
it's not even like don't even pay for it if you don't want to.
It's not about that. I just I genuinely wrote it cuz I feel there's
some important things people might need to know about how the
world works that I learned firsthand the hard way by living it.
And I do apologize uh it took me so long to tell all of you about
the book here on YouTube. I've gotten the emails, "Lauren, are
you dead? You haven't posted in a year." And uh yeah, I was kind
of psychologically deceased for a bit there, so I apologize.
Too much to process. Needed to touch grass. I'm still figuring
out what a healthy relationship with social media looks like,
to be honest. I almost concluded this book by saying we needed
to bomb data centers. Then I decided that might be a little extreme.
I'm joking, CIS. Please leave me alone. Seriously though, it
took some friends dissuading me from the idea that going full
Unabomber cabin in the woods, totally disconnecting, was the
solution to the problems we have right now. I don't think you
can throw the baby out with the bathwater. I just don't want
to feed the distortion machine anymore. I
I I don't want to be a part of how the
How I think about this is I I think this is like
So, here's the issue people have cuz I I feel like I have this
same thing
where I think I could go and just lean into like super partisan
messaging. I think I'm actually quite good at it. I think I could
lean into the populist thing and blow the [__] up.
I really do. I think it'd be pretty simple. I I know the talking
points. I can I can
I understand the thought process, okay? And after watching Fuentes'
success, I think it is very possible to do that. Wouldn't be
as successful as he is, but I think I could do it pretty easily.
I think it's wrong to do that, right? So, I understand this,
but you can absolutely make it as a content creator who does
like honest content as well. It's just not going to be as viral
or as crazy. It's probably going to be a little bit less money
and I think it's less rewarding. Right? It's just overall less
rewarding. It's more work for less money. It's like you could
deal drugs or you could get a desk job. It's like it doesn't
mean the fact that a drug dealer makes more than you doesn't
mean that honest work is bad.
That's that's basically the long and short of it. influencer
ecosystem is working and I'm still figuring that out. I don't
have the answer. Uh so, don't expect this to be any sort of comeback
video or even necessarily a goodbye video. Just if I do post,
it'll be because I have something to say or a project I actually
think is helpful, not because I'm chasing algorithms or trying
to meet a quota. But that's what's killing the internet in my
opinion. And um yeah, if you if you take anything away from this
video or my book if you choose to read it, let it be this. Forget
about me. I'm just another idiot on the internet trying to figure
things out. Uh if you're very upset with my life or what's happened
or decisions I've made or my life, you don't have to live it,
right? This isn't about me. Uh my mistakes or my redemption arc.
Spoiler alert. Uh I feel like this video is disappointing to
me. I I don't even like I I've supported a lot of the other Lauren
pieces that have come out. Uh I I do think she was telling the
truth about Tate. I don't think that she was trying to profit
from that, but now this one feels like
far less like that. This one does feel like over profiteering
and it doesn't feel great. So, I don't know if I'm going to do
anything more, to be honest with you. I I don't know. We'll probably
We'll probably slow down with the Lauren Southern content if
she's going to do more stuff. We'll see. I thought like I was
I was just interested in it and I feel like this has cured me.
Yeah. Yeah, I feel like this has cured me. Although, listen.
Now we'll always get to remember the Central Intelligence Agency
guy, okay, who tried to [__] Lauren Southern and
then she's like, "Dude, this is really weird you're that you're
stalking me right now just to try to make sure I become a government
agent." It's like, "No, he wants to [__] you, actually."
No, it's he very clearly wants to [__]
Very very very clearly. He's sitting on a [__] bench
on a beach smoking with you at it in like the moonlight. He just
wants to [__] you, okay?
Uh almost almost proves a lot of her other things where she like
can't see.
That's like that explains so many of the bad things that have
happened in Lauren's life, okay? Where she absorbs like real
intention for people that's just they want to [__]
you.
That which sucks, by the way. That is its own unique thing that
sucks, but
I I feel like that explains so many things that have gone wrong.
Okay, I'm done with Lauren. I'm done with Lauren.